légère par rapport à la gravité du sujet
merci madame de La Gonterie je vais donc
mettre au vote cette demande de réserve
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour la demande de
réserve qui est contre qui s'abstient la
demande est donc rejetée monsieur le
Président canner donc je euh pardon
monsieur le Président
voilà c'est perturbé de l'article 44 du
règlement la commission des lois demande
la priorité d'examen des amendements
numéro 655 à l'article 3 et numéro 656 à
l'article 4 par ailleurs compte tenu des
sous-amendements qui ont été déposés
depuis la réunion de la commission qui
s'est tenu ce matin nous demanderons une
suspension de séance de de l'ordre de 15
minutes à l'issue de l'examen des
amendements portant article additionnel
après l'article 2 ter enfin j'indique au
commissaire aux lois que nous nous
retrouverons dans la salle
merci merci monsieur le président selon
l'article 44 alinéa 6 de notre règlement
la priorité de droit quand elle est
demandée par la Commission saisie au
fond sauf opposition du gouvernement
j'interroge donc le ministre pour avoir
l'avis du Gouvernement favorable donc la
priorité est ordonnée mes chers
collègues nous allons donc poursuivre
l'examen de ce texte à l'article de BIS
j'ai une demande de parole de Madame
Narain
merci madame la Présidente nous nous
apprêtons donc à examiner l'article 2
bis qui a été introduit en commission
par la droite les républicains c'est
encore une régression inacceptable et
comme l'a déjà dit Monsieur le Ministre
un cavalier
législatif cette disposition vise à
mettre fin à l'acquisition automatique
de nationalité à 18 ans pour les mineurs
qui sont nés en France de parents
étrangers et donc avec cette disposition
on envoie un message terrible à tous ces
jeunes à leurs parents à leurs proches
en leur disant que quoi qu'ils fassent
ils seront toujours renvoyés à leurs
origines à la nationalité de leurs
parents bien que la France soit le seul
pays qu'il aent connu dans toute leur
vie et que ils devront toujours prouver
qu'il méritent d'être français et ça
n'est pas comme cela qu'on améliore
l'intégration dans la République par la
citoyenneté parce que quand on on peut
pas donner envie de s'intégrer dans la
République quand le message de la
République est que on n pas envie de les
accueillir la manifestation de volonté
mes chers collègues ça doit aller dans
les deux sens par ailleurs c'est une
disposition qui avait déjà été
introduite par pascois Charles pascoy en
93 et qui avait été abrogé par le
gouvernement pas en 98 parce que ça ne
fonctionne pas et le rapport Patrick
veille avait démontré que les premières
victime de ces dispositions ce sont les
jeunes filles qui vivent dans des
familles très conservatrices et qui
mettent la pression sur ces jeunes
filles pour qu'elles ne demandent pas la
nationalité et pour tous ceux qui sont
le plus éloignés les plus précaires et
plus les plus éloignés de la chose
publique et donc en plus d'être
inefficace c'est particulièrement
injuste madame la parole est à Madame
audre linkeld
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le ministre
simplement ajouter à ce que vient dire
ma collègue Corine CIN dont je partage
évidemment pleinement les propos que
derrière cette manifestation de la
volonté que que cherche à imposer la
droite sénatoriale pour les jeunes
arrivant à l'âge de 18 ans se cache
plusieurs difficultés qui ont été
rappelées les les femmes qui sont
souvent celles qu'on empêche
malheureusement de manifester cette
volonté les publics les plus fragile et
j'ajouteraiis aussi la discrimination
que cette manifestation de la volonté
créerait au sein même des famille alors
que le principe du droit du sol c'est
que précisément parce qu'on est né sur
le sol français on a un traitement
égalitaire avec toute autre personne né
sur le sol français avec cette
disposition qui est oblig à manifester
sa volonté on aurait au sein d'une même
famille ceux qui auraient manifesté leur
volonté d'être français parce qu'à ce
moment là ils étaient peut-être plus
éclairés moins empêchés et puis on
aurait les autres et on sait très bien
ce que ça génère ensuite comme
difficulté à traiter précisément les les
situations administratives de ces
familles de ces personnes donc cet
amendement évidemment cet article pardon
évidemment est en contradiction totale
avec la conception qui est la N de la
République et de ce droit du sol auquel
nous sommes tant attachés sur lequel
nous aurions évidemment aimé pouvoir
entendre le garde des saau sur encore
une fois un sujet on a bien compris
qu'il n'a normalement rien à faire dans
ce projet de loi sur l'immigration merci
merci Madame nous allons commencer
l'examen de quatre amendements en
discussion commune qui sont quatre
amendements identiques le 22 rectifié
bis présenté par Monsieur
Cabanel merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
c'est un amendement présenté par notre
présidente Marie scarer qui vise à
supprimer cet article cette disposition
adoptée par le Sénat en Commission
prévoit d'ajouter une condition pour
l'accès à la nationalité française d'un
enfant né en France de parents étrangers
celui-ci devrait manifester sa volonté
d'acquérir la nationalité française en
d'autres termes l'accès à la nationalité
française pour ses enfants et
adolescents qui n'ont le plus souvent
pas connu autre chose que la France
c'est cesse d'être automatique notre
commission a donc décidé d'une
résurgence des lois pasquis je le dis
sans détour les signataires de cet
amendement sont contre l'introduction de
ce mécanisme nous inquiète pour des
motifs de fond très évidents nous sommes
attachés à la protection de l'enfance et
nous ne voulons pas conditionner un
destin à une décision prise lors du
passage à la majorité d'un individu je
ne pense pas qu'une formalité
administrative dise véritablement
quelque chose de l'attachement à la
France d'une
personne c'est également une question de
principe nous sommes attachés à la
reconnaissance du droit du sol pour
notre nation cet article va à l'encontre
de ce principe enfin ce qui nous
inquiète d'autant plus c'est que le
gouvernement n'a pas déposé aucun
amendement de suppression de ces
dispositions j'espère donc monsieur le
ministre que vous comptez vous appuyez
sur le nôre merci Monsieur cabanet
l'amendement 169 présenté
par Madame Nar
oui j'espère moi aussi que le
gouvernement soutiendra mais je crois
que Monsieur Darmanin l'a déjà dit tout
à l'heure que a priori il donnera un
avis favorable à ces articles de
suppression puisque il l' dit ce ce
c'est ces articles n'ont rien à faire
dans ce projet de loi mais effectivement
c'est assez inquiétant que le
gouvernement n'est pas jugé bon lui-même
de déposer des amendements de
suppression quand on voit le nombre
d'amendements qui ont été déposés par
ailleurs et et et parfois de manière
totalement
superflu cette cet article de BIS
au-delà de ce que j'ai pu dire déjà tout
à
l'heure il il introduit en plus une
complication dans le droit au-delà
d'être une une
entame à au droit du sol qui est un
droit fondamental qui doit être préservé
dans la République qui est que on a déjà
un régime qui permet de d'acquérir la
nationalité française sur manifestation
de volonté qui est pour les mineurs à
partir de 13 ans jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ans
euh et donc le mettre aussi à l'âge de
de 18 ans euh ça n'a pas beaucoup de
sens de
multiplier ces ces méthodes et puis
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
euh on va on va faire provoquer une
rupture d'égalité dans la République
face à cette acquisition de citoyenneté
de la nationalité française et c'est
quand même un un problème qui n'est pas
tolérable s'il y a bien un domaine dans
lequel l'égalité républicaine doit bien
être absolument respectée c'est bien sur
la question de notre citoyenneté de
notre appartenance à la République et
donc qu'il ait des discriminations qui
se produisent selon le genre de ces
enfants de ces mineurs
ou selon leurs conditions sociales c'est
absolument inacceptable merci beaucoup
chers collègues amendement 286 présenté
par Monsieur
benaroche merci madame la Présidente on
peut s'étonner également comme l'a fait
le président canner de l'ajoute
disposition sur la nationalité dans un
Tex sur l'immigration mais au-delà de
cela je dois dire que la toté notre
groupe se trouve effectivement
excessivement heurté et choqué par les
modifications apportées par cet article
de bis au droit du sol jusqu'à présent
le Code civil disposait que tout enfant
né en France de parents étranger aqu la
nationalité française à sa majorité si à
cette date il a en France sa résidence
ou s'il y a eu sa résidence habituelle
pendant une période continue ou
discontinue d' moins 5 ans depuis l'âge
de Rance qui sont d'une logique absolue
et parfaitement cohérent avec le droit
du sol l'article de B revient sur cet
automatisme ce qui est déjà très grave
puisque il peut mais c'est pas
automatique et puisque la condition
cinequanone une des conditions est qu'il
en manifeste la volonté nous nous
inquiétons comme l'UNICEF avec lequel
nous avons travaillé cet amendement des
conséquences de cette conditionnalité
nouvelle et de ce qui pourrait définir
cette manifestation de volonté
l'exigence d'une manifestation de
volonté n'est pas défini et cela
pourrait engendrer des
décisions alors arbitraires ne le disant
pas aléatoire peut-être diverses de la
part d'autorité administrative de plus
nous craignons que des personnes n'ayant
pas eu accès à cette information avant
leur majorité ou n'ayant pas réaliser
l'importance de cette démarche pour leur
avenir se verront privé de leur
nationalité puisque je rappelle que
cette démarche doit être faite entre
l'âge de 16 et 18 ans l'article
resterait aussi les conditions de
résidence habituelle puisque dans la
dans cet article il s'agit d'une p
période de 5 ans de de 5 ans qui des des
5 dernières années de résidence
habituelle depuis 5
ans résidence habituelle depuis 5
années ça veut dire bien entendu que les
enfants par exemple qui auraient suivi
leurs parents pendant une période d'un
an pour une expérience professionnelle à
l'étranger qui ne pourrait pas justifier
de cette résidence pendant 5 ans ne
pourrait pas demander la nationalité
française merci Monsieur benaroch et
enfin l'amendement 467 qui est présenté
par Monsieur salboldelli
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues faut bien se le dire le le
combat de la droite française pour
restreindre le principe du droit du sol
n'est pas
nouveau on peut même parler d'une idée
fixe voilà c'est reconnu après la mise
en place de la commission marcelon par
le Premier ministre Jacques Chirac c'est
le gouvernement des lois Baladur qui
supprima l'automaticité du droit du sol
pour les jeune de 18 ans nés en France
et résidant depuis une certaine
période ce droit du sol est celui qui
par la naturalisation de ces jeunes qui
ont vocation par leur lieu de naissance
et leur résidence à devenir Français
accompagne toute l'histoire de la
République de 51 à 1927 en passant par
les lois de 1889 le droit du sol s
rentré dans l'histoire de la République
et faut-il rappeler nous le verrons avec
les amendements de Madame Boyer qui est
à l'origine de beaucoup d'ajout
d'ailleurs dans la loi qui nous est
proposé ce sont les nouveaux Français
qui pouvaient éventuellement renoncer à
la nationalité le choix n'était pas
celui d'être français mais le choix
était de ne pas l'être et comment pas et
comment ne pas se rappeler que c'est le
gouvernement de Vichy qui inaugura
l'idée de la remise en cause du droit du
sol avec la mise en place d'une
commission de révision de naturalisation
triste instance qui doit encore faire RV
certains partisans de Madame leupen ou
de Monsieur Zemour c'est l'ordonnance de
1945 issue du combat
main dans la main des Français et
immigrés contre l'occupant nazi qui
instaurera le droit du sol qui
s'applique aujourd'hui dans notre pays
nous n'acceptons pas la demande
dangereuse de la droite sénatoriale qui
au moment où la cohésion sociale de
notre pays est menacée décide de faire
planer le doute sur l'avenir de toute
une jeunesse le droit du sol a une
origine il a une historique il a
supplanté le droit du sang et
rappelez-vous à l'époque on parlait de
sang impur donc cette question est
extrêmement importante et je je crois
que ce qui fonde la République c'est de
concevoir le droit du sol comme une
citoyenneté politique merci Monsieur
savol des avis de la commission sur ces
quatre
amendements cet avis est défavorable je
voudrais éviter le débat historique même
sil a je pense qu'il y a dans les
références par rapport à Monsieur
salelli je pense que c'est un débat qui
a commencé beaucoup plus tôt avant avant
la Première Guerre mondiale et les les
fondements juridiques sont un petit peu
différents de ce que vous avez indiqué
mais je crois pas que ce soit notre
notre sujet à l'heure actuelle le le la
partie de du texte don vous
demandez les quatre groupes là la
suppression résulent effectivement de un
amendement de Madame Boyer qui est
particulièrement attentive à à ces
sujets mais donc il faut bien admettre
nous avons eu la discussion avec elle en
commission qu'elle nous amène à
tangenter les limites de l'article 45
elle le sait nous nous le nous le savons
sur le fond euh puisque l'amendement
avait été déclaré recevable quelle est
notre position le fait de demander une
manifestation de la volonté ne nous
paraît pas normal dans pour un jeune qui
est effectivement né sur le territoire
français mais dont les deux parents sont
étrangers de telle manière qu'il peut
estimer avoir été élevé dans une
communauté à laquelle dont il se
sentirait plus proche donc le fait qu'il
ait une manifestation de la volonté ne
nous choque pas à partir au moment où il
n'y a rien à prouvver puisque c'est ce
que j'ai entendu dans la deuxième
intervention on disait vous demandez à
ce jeune de prouver quelque chose non il
n'a rien à prouver il y a simplement une
manifestation de volonté peut-être un
dernier élément sur cette disposition à
laquelle vous avez attaché le le nom de
de l'ancien ministre monsieur pascois je
ne crois pas que quiconque cherche à
faireevvre la mémoire de Monsieur
pascois à travers cet amendement
simplement vous rappeler que cet
amendement résulté du travail d'une
commission qui était présidée par
marcelong tout le monde se souvient de
son autorité moral comme vice-président
du Conseil d'État et le rapporteur de ce
texte était pierre Mazo dont vous avez
eu l'occasion de souligner l'intégrité
intellectuelleci monsur rapporteur av du
gouvernement merci la présidente un avis
favorable aux amendement de de
suppression ce c'est sujet de code de
nationalité n'ont rien à faire dans ce
texte sur le droit des étrangers en
France très bien donc je vais mettre au
voix ces amendements pardon monsieur
carucci je ne vous ai pas vu
pardonnez-moi madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je vais pas
m'exprimer sur le fond chacun votre ser
en conscience mais je voudrais dire au
ministre une fois n'est pas coutume que
je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui ça ilut
il faut que ça arrive il faut que ça se
produise parce que comme j'ai appris
tout à l'heure que vous remodeliez la
droite autour de vous je voudrais quand
même que que je puisse dire quelque
chose mais ou inversement oui oui ça
c'est vrai euh dans le en même temps
tout est possible non mais je je ne suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec le
ministre pour une raison simple c'est
que en réalité il faut arrêter de dire
que le droit du sol c'est un principe
républicain ça n'est pas vrai en réalité
le premier texte je l'ai dit dans la
discussion générale mais les gens
écoutent ou
pas le premier texte sur les mouvements
migratoires c'est le texte de 1889 qui
est à la fois un texte sur l'acquisition
de la nationalité et sur les mouvements
migratoires et déjà en 1889 on faisait
le lien et pardon de dire parce que je
vois que certains veulent faire
absolument du droit du sol principe
républicain que les débats de 1889 à la
Chambre des députés vous serez pas déçu
ça n'a strictement rien à voir avec la
République simplement nous étions dans
une période de grande faiblesse
démographique par rapport à l'Allemagne
et le législateur s'est dit il faut
renforcer le nombre de français pour
avoir des troupes si nous repartons à la
bataille contre l'Allemagne et on a
décidé alors il faut voir les débats
sont sont d'un cru qu'on n'imagine pas
les les uns et les autres faisant leur
petit calcul de savoir come ça faisait
de soldat en plus par régiment donc
c'est c'est pas un principe républicain
c'est un principe de réalité oui c'est
pas un principe républicain mais je ne
vois pas en quoi monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez être opposé à toute
modification du droit du sol mais je ne
trouve pas que ces amendements ou ces
articles ou cet article n''est pas de
sens dans cette loi monsieur le
ministre monsieur ministre car une fois
également vous disiez tout à l'heure on
écoute écoute ou pas àction discussion
générale je ne sais pas si vous étiez
tardivement hier avec avec nous mais on
écoute ou pas non plus parce que je me
suis clairement exprimé et je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs à la tribune lors de mon
expression publique pour la dire la
discussion générale que le gouvernement
ne s'exprime pas sur l'opportunité de
telle ou telle disposition prévue par la
commission des lois sur le droit de la
nationalité il considère qu'il n'y a
rien à voir dans ce texte c'est un
cavalier pur et simple qui a été rajouté
je l'ai dit plusieurs fois au rapporteur
et président de la commission des lois
l'irrecevabilité bon évidemment si vous
en êtes le seul juge bon et je je disais
que la plupart la quasi intégralité des
textes sur les droits des étrangers ne
mélange pas le Code civil et le le droit
des étrangers d'ailleurs si nous
l'avions fait sans doute que le Conseil
d'État aurait dijoint cette disposition
vous le savez bien donc je vous dis
simplement que nous parlons de choses
qui sont déjà assez compliquées comme ça
le droit des étrangers rajouter des
articles du Code de la nationalité me me
me paraît d'abord aller vers le cavalier
évident et donc la sension du conseil
Suelle j'ai crains que la haute
assemblée se perde du temps même sur des
sujets très intéressants parfois vitau
mais qui ne correspondont pas au droit
des Français qu'il y aura le lendemain
la publication de de la loi et donc
ainsi va désespérer un peu plus ce qui
coûte nos débats deuxièmement je ve dire
à à au ministre au ministre cauchci le
le le sujet du code de la nationalité
peut se porter dans d'autres moments le
projet de loi du gouvernement des
proposition de loi évidemment de la part
de la haute de l'Assemblée nationale et
dans ces cas-là évidemment on est prêt à
en discuter mais mon opposition je le
répète pour tout article qui touche le
code de la cté des articles de la
commission des lois créées par la
commission des lois ou des amendements
c'est nous considérons que c'est un
cavalier pur et simple c'est pour ça que
mes avis sont favorables aux suppression
parce que j'essaie d'être cohérent et de
rappeler à chacun que c'est un cavalier
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
Rossignol euh en fait il a quelque chose
de vraiment très choquant dans la
proposition j'entrerai pas dans le débat
euh que le sur est-ce que ça a sa place
ou pas dans ce texte mais dans la
proposition que vous faites il y a
quelque chose d'assez choquant et
d'assez euh une grande méconnaissance de
ce qu'est un adolescent entre 16 et 18
ans en fait vous imposez à ces jeunes de
demander la nationalité française entre
16 et 18 ans après 18 ans si j'ai bien
compris la porte se ferme et il est
obligé de passer par une demande de
naturalisation c'est ça que vous
proposez 16 18 ans d'abord c'est un
mineur donc l'idée que il puisse à ce
moment là avoir un conflit affectif avec
ses parents ne vous a pas effleuré
l'esprit en fait vous demandez à un
mineur de fait de faire une démarche qui
est une démarche quasiment d'adulte
entre 16 et 18 ans combien sont informés
de leur droit combien savent que c'est
le moment pendant lequel il faudrait
demander cette nationalité qu'après la
porte se ferme
aucun probablement très peu et puis
enfin je comprends pas votre approche
globale de ce que veut dire selon vous
faire nation ce texte est destiné à
lutter contre les étrangers qui entre en
france d' situation irrégulière et qui
voudrait y rester bien qu'il n'y ait pas
droit là nous avons affaire à des
enfants qui sont en France en situation
régulière qui doivent faire nation avec
nous et vous leur fermez la porte de
faire nation avec nous en fait vous
fabriquez des gens extérieurs à la
nation française nous n'avons vraiment
pas la même conception de ce que veut
dire faire
nation merci Madame Rossignol monsieur
salbelli
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre mais mais ah si je m'enlève
le son monsieur le rapporteur général
vous avez demandé de mettre l'histoire
de côté ce que vous n'avez pas fait et
ça je fais pas moi qui veut vous en
faire le
reproche j'ai plutôt il plutôt coutomier
de pas être d'accord avec Roger carucci
jamais je lui demanderai et il ne me
demandera de mettre l'histoire de côté
c'est normal que l'histoire nourrisse
nos débats ici dans le C hémicycle dès
que le peuple français il a eu la
possibilité de s'exprimer il a inscrit
le droit du sol dans les fondements de
notre nation à la Révolution tout homme
ayant vécu un an sur notre territoire
pouvait devenir français et pourquoi
parce que la France est constituée comme
une nation politique et une nation
politique qui s'exerce en tant que telle
de par la
citoyenneté la France n'est pas une
nation religieuse la France n'est pas
une nation
ethnique la France est une nation
politique depuis que le siècle des
Lumières a fait triomphé la liberté et
l'égalité en dépit de la
tyrannie et avant cela les Français
n'étaient que des sujets du roi et j'y
ai fait état tout à l'heure on leur dit
disait que leur sang était impur
contrairement au sang bleu de
l'aristocratie c'est bien deentendre
tout ça et c'est pour ça que le peuple a
refusé le droit du sang parce que le
droit du sol est la garantie
fondamentale de l'égalité des droits et
remettre cela en cause comme vous le
faites c'est ce que je considère c'est
remettre en cause les principes mêmees
de la République donc c'est un sujet
extrêmement grave et important merci
monsieuroldelli Monsieur benarocheoch
monsieur le
rapporteur
oui je ne m'attendais pas forcément à ce
que nous rentrions dans un débat sur les
grands principes je partage je l'avais
abordé bien sûr la lecture historique
présentée par Monsieur KCI et j'avais
bien entendu son intervention de la
discussion générale monsieur salodil
vous poser quand même une question qui
est particulièrement importante en
considérant que le droit du sol fait
partie de nos grands principes
républicains
euh j'ai je je me suis permis de
vérifier parce que euh bien sûr le texte
de 93 a été soumis à l'appréciation du
Conseil constitutionnel et je vous lis
la réponse du Conseil constitutionnel
considérant que la loi déféré dispose
que l'acquisition de la nationalité
française doit faire l'objet d'une
manifestation de volonté de la part de
l'intéressé ce dont nous sommes en train
de parler que s'agissant d'une telle
condition misise à l'acquisition de la
nationalité française par l'effet de la
naissance sur le territoire français le
droit du sol il était loisible au
législateur de les dicter sans porter
atteinte à un principe de valeur
constitutionnelle que dès lors le
grriillef évoqué et cetera simplement on
a bien compris votre votre propos je
vous dis simplement que le Conseil
constitutionnel vous a répondu ça c'est
simplement pour l'information générale
ce n'est pas totalement le débat sur ces
amendements mais entendez quand même la
réponse de 93 du Conseil constitutionnel
merci monsieur le rapporteur je mets
donc au voix ces qu amendement avec un
avis défavorable de la commission un
avis favorable du gouvernement qui est
pour l'adoption de ces
amendements qui est
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés nous avons ensuite C amendements
en discussion commune le 524 présenté
par Monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente le
droit du sol est devenu un dogme auquel
il faut croire à l'origine et cela a été
parfaitement dit par notre collègue
sénateur kucci à l'origine le droit du
sol a été créé c'est un fait historique
hein j'ai le droit d'être d'accord avec
lui c'est c'est un fait historique
le droit du sol le droit du sol a été
créé pour une raison simple faire face à
la poussée démographique allemande et
rendre nos armées capables de mettre
autant d'hommes sur le front en cas de
mobilisation générale or s'il y a bien
une invasion aujourd'hui elle ne vient
pas de l'autre côté du rein à quel titre
donne-t-on la nation nationalité
française à quelqu'un uniquement par le
hasard de son lieu de naissance si
depuis il vit qu'avec des étrangers et
se comporte en France comme un étranger
suivre l'école de la République n'est en
aucun cas suffisant surtout aujourd'hui
puisqu'on y apprend que la France n'est
qu'une vague idée et plus une patrie
charnelle je rappelle qu'en 2016 selon
l'ifope 47 % des lycéens français
musulmans placer la charia au-dessus des
lois de la République 4 ans plus tard en
200 20 c'était 57 % vous voyez que
l'école de la République ne fait pas
tout un enfant sur 6 qui né en France
aujourd'hui l' de deux parents étranger
hors Union Européenne quand c'était
moins de 1/1 en 2001 depuis 2017 chaque
année c'est plus de 60000 personnes nées
de parents non communautaires qui vont
pouvoir demander le droit du sol 360000
personnes une ville comme Nice qui
devrait devenir français par par le
simple fait d'être né sur le territoire
national pourquoi ce qui a été fait à
Mayotte avec la suspension du droit du
sol ne pourrait pas être fait en
métropole
selon l'ifope en 2018 52 % des Français
sont favorables à la suppression du
droit du sol en 2020 ce sont 58 % des
Français qui sont favorables un veau qui
n'est dans une écurie ne fera jamais
jamais de lui un cheval ça les Français
l'ont parfaitement compris mes chers
collègues c'est à vous de l'admettre
enfin la suppression de cette stupide
loi du sol est autant une évidence
qu'une
urgence merci Monsieur ravier je propose
qu'on reste dans des termes corrects
pour nos
concitoyens nous avons ensuite quatre
amendements quatre amendements présentés
par Madame Boyer madame Boyer je vous
propose de les présenter à la suite
parce que je crois qu'il y a des
amendements de repli dedans merci madame
la Présidente écoutez les amendements
sont en discussion commune mais je
n'emploierai pas les mêmes termes que
certains je voulais simplement rappeler
que dès 2012 à la suite de l'arrivée de
du président Hollande à l'Élysée une
forte augmentation s'est produite pour
l'immigration
210940 en 2014 250
en 2015 242000 en 2017
2550550 en 2018
266600 en 2019 315000 en 2022 après la
parenthèse des années covid c'est alors
que la France semble avoir perdu la
maîtrise de son immigration les
acquisitions de la nationalité ont
augmenté entre 2017 et 2021 de 53,6 %
slevant à
130385 naturalisation à cette date les
conditions d'accès à la nationalité
notamment pour les mineurs restent
relativement favorables et peuvent
potentiellement renforcer l'attractivité
du territoire français ainsi en
commission des lois nous avons souhaité
resserrer les conditions d'acquisition
de la nationalité française pour les
mineurs étrangers nés en France de
parents étrangers d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre on s'est exprimé là-dessus hier
soir permettez-moi de regretter que
l'accès à la nationalité qui favorise
l'immigration soit un des sujets
occultés du projet de loi initiale et ça
me semble être en parfaite contradiction
avec l'objet du texte que nous avons à
examiner qui s'intitule immigration et
intégration et je pense que
l'acquisition de la nationalité c'est le
le le la fin de l'intégration puisque on
devient français j'ai même par exemple
fait voter un amendement tentant à
subordonner l'acquisition de ces
personnes à la nationalité à une
manifestation de la volonté comme ce fut
le cas comme ça a été en vigueur des
années précédentes mais aujourd'hui nous
devons aller plus loin c'est pourquoi
cet amendement issu de notre proposition
de loi tant à prolonger inention déjà
portée par le texte de la Commission
visant à mettre fin à l'automaité de
l'acquisition de la nationalité en
raison de la naissance et de sa
résidence sur le territoire français
droit du sol pour les mineurs étrangers
nés en France de parents étrangers il
prévoit ainsi que l'acquisition de la
nationalité par cette fois serait
conditionné à la manifestation de la
volonté comme nous l'avions souhaité et
que la durée de la résidence habituelle
sur le territoire soit doublée pour être
portée à 10 ans je voudrais simplement
vous faire remarquer que lorsque la loi
pasquy en 93 avait mis en place la la
manifestation de la volonté ça avait pas
créer de désordre la nationalité
pourrait donc également être acquise par
réclamation anticipée à compôté de 13
ans du mineur concerné tout en
maintenant une condition de résidence
habituelle de 10 ans par ailleurs cet
amendement prévoit bien évidemment des
coordinations rendu nécessairire pour le
cas de Mayotte et enfin je voudrais
simplement rajouter que effectivement
ces amendements je les avais présentés
d'une certaine façon lorsque j'avais
lorsque j'étais député et que nous
avions discuté de la loi colon et que je
regrette qu'à ce moment-là et bien on
nit pas pu avancer sur ce sujet qui me
semble absolument majeur et enfin si on
ne parle pas de la nationalité dans ce
texte quand allons-nous en parler c'est
ça aussi le sujet on nous avait annoncé
un texte sur l'immigration le le grand
soir de un grand texte et si on ne peut
pas parler de tous ces sujets qui me
semblent majeurs je ne me demande quand
on va en parler aujourd' aujourd'hui et
ça me semble être central et rentrer
totalement dans le cadre du texte que
nous examinons je vous remercie très
bien les amendements suivant sont des
repli c'est bien ça les amendements
suivants sont différents puisqu'il
s'agit pour le 66 de restreindre les
conditions de la nationalité au titre
droit du sol il s'agit de réserver
l'acquisition de la nationalité aux
personnes clairement engagées ainsi que
leur environnement proche dans une
démarche volontaire d'assimilation pour
le
66 pour
le excusez-moi pour pour le 69 il s'agit
de subordonner en France métropolitaine
le bénéfice du droit du sol au séjours
régulier de 2 années sur le territoire
national pour les deux parents et pour
le 70 qui est lui un amendement de repli
de subordonner en France métropolitaine
le bénéfice du droit du sol au séjours
régulier de 2 années sur le territoire
national d'un des deux parents je
rappelle que nous avons déjà pris un
certain nombre de dispositions
concernant des territoires français
particulier comme Mayotte pourquoi pour
faire face justement aux difficultés qui
sont les nôtres et je me permets attirer
votre attention sur des faits qui me
semblent d'une particulière d'une
particulière gravité hier nous avons
évoqué les MNA autre d'ailleurs sujet
euh qui n'est pas traité dans ce texte
et je le regrette euh bien évidemment ça
a été dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure aux
questions au gouvernement et aujourd'hui
nous assistons sur une bonne partie du
territoire français que ce soit en
France métropolitaine ou à maot à des
jeunes filles mineures qui arrivent
enceintes en France ou pour pouvoir
avoir cette espèce de totem
d'immunité avoir un enfant en France
cette situation absolument désespérante
et désespérée participe aujourd'hui au
trafic d'êtres humains participe aux
maltraitances dont sont victimes ses
jeunes femmes ces très jeunes femmes et
je pense que aujourd'hui restreindre les
conditions nous permettrait de
restreindre ces situation désespérante
et désespéré à la fois pour elle mais
aussi pour les situations qui en
découlent donc euh je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les signaux que nous
donnons sur la restriction du droit du
sol nous permettraiit effectivement de
faire en sorte que ces très jeunes
personnes qu'elles soient mineures réell
ou pas et bien ne puissent pas être dans
cette situation extrêmement dure quand
vous pensez qu'à Mayotte on demande des
kits d'accouchement pour les personnes
qui arrivent par bateau vous voyez quand
même bien la situation absolument
abominable dans lesquelles on se trouve
et on assiste aujourd'hui dans nos
départements à de plus en plus de jeune
fille qui arrive en France
métropolitaine dans ces conditions voilà
pour vous présenter tous les amendements
mais bien évidemment c'est l'amendement
344 qui est l'amendement du groupe qui
que je voulais vous présenter de façon
plus large je vous remerci merci
beaucoup madame Boyer avis de la
commission sur ces amendements monsieur
le
rapporteur nous sommes pardon nous
sommes défavorables au 524 de Monsieur
ravier au 66 de Madame Boyer au 69 au 70
de Madame Boyer avec une réserve sur le
avec une sagesse pardon sur le 344 de
Madame Boyer premièrement je je vous
prie de
m'excuser je m'adresse à l'ensemble des
collègues je m'aperçois que nous sommes
en train de partir dans des débats on
adore nous sommes nombreux à adorer
l'histoire mais à vouloir évoquer
l'histoire qui est absolument
passionnante nous nous trouvons derrière
avec des déclarations excessives je fais
bien sûr référence à celle de de
Monsieur ravier il faut faire attention
que nous ne perdions pas le le fil de
notre discussion et et de la nécessaire
tranquillité ou par la nécessaire
sérénité je retire tranquillité la
nécessaire sérénité de nos discussions
euh le le l'amendement de Monsieur
ravier ne peut qu'être écarté puisque là
c'est
manifestement inconstitutionnel
sur les amendements de Madame Boyer nous
sommes amenés à demander un avis
défavorable sur les principaux il y a eu
déjà suffisamment de difficultés à faire
admettre par le Conseil d'État puis par
le Conseil constitutionnel une règle
particulière dérogatoire sur Mayotte qui
avait été fixé à un parent en situation
régulière et 3 mois imaginez de demander
cette même règle pour la métropole pour
les deux parents et sur une période de 2
ans vous avez également un amendement
repli sur 1 an sur 2 ans pardon pour un
un pour un seul parent il est évident
que là on a des
inconstitutionnalités majeur le 344 nous
avons prévu une sagesse madame Boyer
parce qu'il avait l'avantage de répondre
à la question de maris sigin concernant
le le mécanisme juridique à mettre en
place pour la déclaration volontaire
c'est vraiment une sagesse du bout des
lèvres parce que vous demandez également
de prolonger le délai de résidence de 5
ans à à 10 ans nous sommes déjà je
comprends que vous prépariez le débat
quelque part on prépare le débat pour la
CMP mais on est déjà très limite sur
l'article 45 vous appuyez vous appuyer
sur le sur la sonnerie en disant en plus
il faut passer à 10 ans je vous laisse
apprécier apprécier là-dessus euh la
suite de la suite des des opérations en
tout cas de notre part c'est une sagesse
sur le
344 merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre et ensuite monsieur
Guay pour un rappel au règlement
oui je je voudrais dire trois choses en
donnant un avis défavorable évidemment
aux amendements de Madame Boyet pour les
raisons que j'ai évoqué mais bien plus
que cela dire quand même que je souigne
que le rapporteur du texte dit lui-même
qu'il est à la limite de l'article 45 je
je le dis pour le pour la lecture pour
la lecture des débats par le Conseil
constitutionnel euh le deuxème sujet
dire à à Monsieur ravier que ça
comparaison des humains avec les animaux
ne l'honore
pas vous auriez pu prendre une autre
image monsieur ravier mais manifestement
votre conscience vre inconscience parle
elle vous honore pas et je pense que un
ministre de la République ne peut pas ne
rien dire quand il est au ban dans
devant les représentations nationales
[Applaudissements]
voilà madame présidente a dit des choses
si je peux permettre je vais pas faire
la correction de madame la Présidente
mais elle a pris ses propos si je dire
voilà Mame la présidente de prendre
votre défense mais vous savez bien que
c'est un bonheur troisièmement dire à
Madame Boyer sonans rentrer dans le
détail de tout ce texte en tout cas
puisque je je me refuse ce débat sur le
code de la nationalité un petit mot sur
maotte quand même parce que Madame
voyez je je m'en excuse mais vous parlez
d'un d'un temps ancien pour Mayotte
puisque c'est ce gouvernement-ci qui a
modifié les règles à Mayotte d'accès à
la régularisation à la nationalité
puisque non mais pour que tous ceux qui
nous suivent sont pas tous spécialistes
du droit appliqué à maotte
désormais pour pouvoir avoir l'accès à
la régularisation et demain possiblement
à la nationalité il faut être arrivé sur
le territoire de maotte avec au moins un
des deux parents qui sont réguliers ou
nationaux et deuxièmement être arrivé 3
mois au moins avant la conception de
l'enfant donc quel une partie oriante
qui serait dans les conditions
d'accouchement sur un coina comme rien
n'aurait pas évidemment le droit à la
régularation et n'aurait pas nationalité
faut-il aller plus in ça c'est pas
l'accès à la nationalité c'estment
l'accès à la
régularisation je pense qu'il le faut et
il y aura des amendements notamment de
de nos collègues de vos collègues
sénateurs du groupe RDPI des deux
sénateurs sont désormais au groupe RDPI
à mayott qui évoque le fait de passer à
9 mois la conception de l'enfant et que
les deux parents soient réguliers voilà
mais ce n'est pas mais justement c'est
fait exprès pour que évidemment il y ait
pas de calcul de conception de enfant
pour avoir la régularisation c'est
exactement pour ça que ces sénateurs y
pensent et donc je pense que c'est des
amendements coincés évidemment dans dans
le débat sur si la nationalité qui ne
relève pas de la nationalité qui relève
de la régularisation plus tard alors
est-ce qu'ils sont constitutionnels ces
amendement on a un doute puisque
lorsqu'on avait fait le projet de loi
qui prévoyait effectivement le passage à
3 mois et un des deux par an régulier le
Conseil constitutionnelle mais surtout
le Conseil d'État nous avait dit
attention vous êtes à la limite 2 avant
la réforme constitutionnelle on va
tenter pour Mayotte évidemment cette
réforme moi je donnerai un avis
favorable des deux parents réguliers ou
français qui ont sont arrivé avant 9
mois non mais là vous parlez pas de
maotte vous parlez d'ensemble du
territoire national et vous parlez
l'accès à la nationalité moi je parle de
la régularisation c'est pour ça que je
me permets de le préciser et
effectivement peut-être qu'il faud
retirer des des questions
constitutionnelles pour maot si jamais
le Conseil consnel vait à censurer à
disposition pour la régularisation en
tout cas le gouvernement il est prêt un
avis défavorable sinon sur les autres
questions du fait que ça rentre dans le
code de la nationalité merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur Fabien guet pour un
rappel au règlement
oui merci Madame la président monsieur
le ministre rappel au règlement fondé
sur l'article 32 sur la tenue de notre
séance madame la Présidente vous savez
que notre groupe est attaché au débat
démocratique et républicain parfois et
moi j'aime les personnes qui ont des
convictions et qui les affirment et
après on a des désaccords et ce n'est
pas grave et c'est pour ça que parfois
on peut faire référence à l'histoire ce
n'est pas grave et tant mieux avec des
valeurs que nous défendons j'ai un
désaccord avec Monsieur kucci euh et ce
n'est pas grave et ce n'est pas le
premier c'est pas le dernier et chacun
les a fier mais les affronte mais ce
qu'a dit notre collègue ravier est
indigne et intolérable comparé dans un
débat sur le droit du sol des hommes et
des femmes à des animaux n'est pas
acceptable et quel que soit soit notre
position sur la question du droit du sol
tous les républicains qui sommes ici
dans cet hémicycle doivent le condamner
lourdement je le dis avec force parce
que ce n'est pas acceptable si nous
continuons à dériver comme cela si un
racisme décomplexé peut s'exprimer
librement prendre la parole librement
dans cet hémicycle alors nous
basculonsons à autre chose je le redis
notre groupe condamne fermement ses
propos et j'espère que chacun s emploira
je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Guay je donne la
parole à Madame la rapporteur madame
joura merci madame la Présidente moi
aussi je voulais évoquer les propos qui
viennent d'être du par Monsieur ravier
qui nous explique que un Vau quiinait
dans une écuride ne vient pas un cheval
d'abord je crois qu'il faut un peu
tempérer les condamnations
intempestive si on transmet l'image et
si on la transcrit les étranger etlevau
et le français le cheval dire tout le
monde là-dedans est comparé à un animal
ça n'est pas d'une grande élégance je le
reconnaît mais nous sommes tous ravalés
au rang de bêtes dans cette histoire
surtout ce qui me heurte le plus dans
cette dans ce propos c'est je crois que
sur le fond il est faux il est faux
parce que la France est un pays
universaliste la France est un pays dans
lequel on peut devenir Français
autrement que par la naissance
autrement que par le sol on peut devenir
Français indépendamment de sa couleur de
peau indépendamment de sa religion
indépendamment de son orientation
sexuelle et indépendamment de son
origine la réalité c'est
qu'effectivement en France quelqu'un qui
n'est pas né français peut devenir
français ça s'appelle l'assimilation et
ça implique d'adhérer à la totalité de
ce qu'elle la
France merci Madame la rapporteur
monsieur BR a demandé la parole non vous
l'avez pas demandé très bien monsieur
ravier pour explication de
vote merci madame la Présidente il ne
s'agit aucunement de ma part de
vouloir renvoyer les êtres humains au
rang d'animaux que ce soit les étrangers
ou des Français c'est une image c'est la
situation que je compare ce n ce ne sont
pas la les êtres
humains si j'ai pu froisser certains
j'en suis navré mais il il n'est pas
dans ma dans ma dans ma volonté de
comparer ou de ramener les les êtres les
êtres humains à des animaux mais quand
même me faire non non mais en plus ou
alors mais mais me faire faire la leçon
sur de démocratie de respect des êtres
humains par un représentant du parti
communiste il faut quand même oser se
réclamer du communisme c'est-à-dire de
l'idéologie qui euh au au cours de ce au
cours de ces derniers millénaires a
provoqué la mort de 100 millions de
personnes a privé de liberté syndical
professionnelle religieuse toutes les
libertés fondamentales des millions
d'individus monsieur Guay vous devriez
vous faire plus modeste vous faire plus
discret dans cette dans ce combat pour
la démocratie et pour la liberté quand
on se réclame du communisme c'est une
honte il y a eu il y a eu fort
heureusement il y a eu fort heureusement
le nurember du nazisme il faudra bien
qu'il y ait un jour le nurember du
communisme 100 millions de morts et vous
osez nous faire la leçon sur la
démocratie la liberté honte à vous honte
à vous mes chers collègues je souhaite
que nos débats conservent de la sérénité
qui fait la marque de fabrique de notre
assemblée et contribue à la bonne image
de nos travaux je n'hésiterai pas afin
de maintenir la sérénité de nos débats à
faire faire usage des prérogatives que
le règlement confère à la présidence de
séance ce rappel ayant été fait nous
reprenons le cours normal de la
discussion je donne la parole à Madame
de la ganterie puis monsieur pardon
pardon madame de la ganterie voilà je
donne la parole pour 2 minutes au
ministre madame merci la présidente
lorsque je me suis exprimé la tribune je
me suis engagé comme ministre évidemment
à ce qu'on a des débats respectueux des
personnes je pense que c'est pas le cas
je vous demande 2 minutes de suspension
de séance
je suspends donc la séance pour 2
minutes
voilà il est 17h24 bienvenue si vous
êtes sur l'antainne de Public Sénat et
que vous nous rejoignez depuis 1hure et
bien le Sénat a repris l'examen du
projet de loi immigration après la
séance des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement nous sommes dans l'article
2 bis cela concerne des mesures mure
ajouté par le Sénat en commission sur et
bien le retour sur l' l'automaticité du
droit de l'acquisition de la nationalité
hein c'est donc des mesures autour du
droit du sol et on le voit depuis une
dizaine de minutes des propos de
Stéphane Ravier le sénateur reconquête
proche d'Éric Zemour et bien ces propos
ont suscité l'indignation de nombreux
sénateur et donc il y a au moment où l'
se parle une suspension de séance pour
que tout le monde puisse et bien
retrouver la sérénité comme vient de
dire la présidente de séance Sophie
prima pour en parler on peut aller
rejoindre et bien le journaliste qui va
m'accompagné tout l'après-midi sur
public toute la soirée sur Public Sénat
Mathias SZ bonjour Mathias vous êtes en
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle
effectivement on a entendu ces propos de
Stéphane Ravier et depuis il y a eu une
cascade de réaction c'est ça qui s'est
joué oui absolument ça fait un peu plus
de de 10 minutes maintenant he que les
sénateurs s'écharpent suite à cet
amendement défendu par le sén sénateur
reconquête Stéphane Ravier pour revenir
sur le le droit du sol he c'était le le
cœur des débats ici lors lors de ces
amendements Stéphan ravier qui comme
vous l'avez dit a comparé les étrangers
à des veaux et des Français à à des à
des chevaux des des paroles qui ont fait
réagir dans sur tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle notamment du côté des
communistes ou Fabien Guay lors d'un
rappel au réglement est revenu avec
fermeté en condamnant les propos de
Stéphane Ravier le le ministre Gérald
haranin a lui dit qu'il souhaitait des
débats apaisés qu'il fallait revenir au
texte ce qu'a également demandé la
présidente de séance Sophie prima de
séance par dans l'hémicyclle pour
écouter mariere de la gonriie il a un
nouvel rappel règlement d'ailleurs
effectivement le règlement prévoit toute
une série de mesures qui vous permet de
faire revenir l'ordre pour ceux qui ne
viendrai pas spontanément nous nous
associons totalement aux propos qui ont
été tenus notamment par Fabien Guay ça
c'est une chose explication de vote nous
voterons contre tous ces amendements et
je dirais par ailleurs au au rapporteur
je suis très étonné que sur l'un des
amendements sur lequel il exprime
lui-même un doute sérieux on va dire les
choses comme ça car il est très courtois
avec ses collègues sur la compatibilité
avec la Constitution que ça l'amène à à
donner un avis de sagesse lorsquun
amendement vous semble inconstitutionnel
il me semble qu'il faut donner un avis
défavorable voilà donc je je pense que
c'est un petit problème de précaution de
langage quant à Madame Jourda qu'
qu'elle banalise les propos de Monsieur
ravier
m'inquiète président retaillot pour une
explication de vote
oui je vous remercie d'ailleurs madame
la Présidente d'avoir fait ce rappel au
règlement si j'ose dire tout comme je
voudrais souligner que notre collègue au
début de son propos je n'étais pas là
lorsque l'incident de séance est arrivé
mais avait elle-même remis les choses au
point avec justesse ce que jeux
simplement dire parce que j'entends les
articles 45 j'entends le problème de
constitutionnalité nous sommes sous la
5e République et désormais un parlement
qui est assez largement diminué
l'article 40 l'article 41 l'article 45
si nous-même nous commençons à nous
autocensurer parce qu'on craint une
censure de conseil constitionnel mais
alors on n pas on n plus législateur un
certain nombre et le gouvernement
lui-même mes collègues on nétait pas
d'accord à nouveau sur la loi retraite
nous avions très bien décelé qu'il y
avait deux enez-vous il y avait deux
articles ostensiblement ils se sont
d'ailleurs fait censurer le gouvernement
lui-même les proposait le gouvernement
c'était pas drappé dans un manteau
d'indignité constitutionnelle pour dire
je je les retire donc je je pense que
parfois il faut aller au bout d'un
certain nombre de conviction et puis
après on est censuré on l''est pas
parfois d'ailleurs on a étit
heureusement surpris donc je je plaide
plutôt moi sur ces questions d'article
d'inconstitutionnalité à à à aller au au
bout des démarches au niveau politique
c'est c'est le législateur et c'est
notre travail
aussi monsieur le Président je vous
propose que nous passions au vote de ces
amendements je mets au voir l'amendement
524 de Monsieur ravier qui a un double
avis des pardon on n'a pas eu le l'avis
du ministre on n pas eu l'avis du
ministre si pardon avis excusez-moi avis
défavorable pardonnez-moi excusez-moi
monsieur le ministre donc un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour cet amendement
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté sur l'amendement 344 je suis
saisie d'une demande de scrutin publ du
groupe écologist solidarité et
territoire alors l'avis est un avis de
sagesse par la Commission et un avis
défavorable du
gouvernement
le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc
clos voici les résultats de ce vote V
343 exprimé
343 pour 133 contre 210 l'amendement
n'est pas adopté je mets au voix
l'amendement 66 rectifié avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour l'adoption du
66 qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
amendement 69 rectifié avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour l'adoption de
cet amendement qui est contre qui tient
il n'est pas adopté et amendement 70
rectifié avec deux avis défavorables
même vote même vote il n'est pas
adopté voilà voilà je mets au voix
l'article 2 bis qui est pour l'adoption
de l'article 2
bis qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article de BIS nous
sommes saisis d'un amendement 345 qui
est présenté par Monsieur blan
madame
[Musique]
asliman quelqu'un du groupe LR il est
défendu il est défendu avis de la
commission
favorable favorable avis du
gouvernement favorable je mets donc
défavorable je mets donc au voix cet
amendement 345 avec un avis favorable de
la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté nous avons un amendement 62
rectifié présenté par Madame
Boyer écoutez nous allons continuer le
le débat puisque cet amendement permet à
l'autorité publique de s'opposer à
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française par l'effet du droit du sol
d'un étranger qui s'est manifestement
pas assimilé à la Communauté française
et l'assimination resterait ainsi
présumée à la différence du régime de
naturalisation mais l'état aura la
possibilité d'apporter la preuve de la
nonassimination et de s'opposer ainsi à
l'acquisition de la nationalité par le
droit du sol donc voilà la teneur de cet
amendement mer madame Boyet avis de la
commission l'avis de la commission
madame la Présidente a porter sur cet
amendement dont je rappelle euh que le
périmètre de l'article 45 a permis d'y
intégrer puisqu'il a été voté par la
commission alors sur cet amendement qui
prévoit une condition d'assimilation
préalable l'acquisition de la
nationalété par le droit du sol il
reprend en réalité une condition qui
existe déjà pour l'acquisition de la NA
de la nationalité pardon par
naturalisation l'amendement pourrait
être un peu précisé dans sa rédaction
mais
toutefois en raison du premier élément
précité c'est un avis de sagesse de la
commission avis du
gouvernement déforable défavorable je
mets au voix cet amendement avec un avis
de sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est donc
adopté nous sommes ensuite saisis d'un
amendement 628 présenté par la
commission madame la rapporteur
ou
monsieurte
nous sommes
pardon nous sommes là dans une un
article additionnel après l'article de
bis et nous sommes à maotte à guyan et à
Saint-Martin c'est le débat qui vous a
été présenté il y a quelques secondes
par le ministre de l'Intérieur répondant
sur un autre amendement
euh nous avons tous en mémoire le
l'amendement qui a été porté par par tan
soli sénateur de Mayot sur la règle un
parent présent sur le sol français
depuis plus de 3 mois ceci faisait suite
à une interrogation qui avait été
formulée par le président du Sénat
auprès du Conseil d'État pour savoir si
finalement on pouvait
envisager de faire une exception pour
Mayotte et la réponse du Conseil d'État
avait été de dire oui et donc nous
avions suivi la proposition monsieur
soli en retenant ce délai de 3 mois
l'idée dans cette disposition au regard
d'une situation tout à fait particulière
pours Mayotte mais tenant compte
également d'une situation tout à fait
particulière sur la Guyane où le niveau
de l'immigration est particulièrement
important avec les sujets que tout le
monde connaît du Surinam et du Brésil
tenant compte aussi d'une situation
exceptionnelle sur Saint-Martin
avec Haïti en situation totale des
confitures à côté nous avons ciblé une
mesure qui prend en compte la réalité du
terrain en proposant d'étendre le délai
à 1 an pour Mayotte à 9 mois pour la
Guyane et d'introduire cette disposition
dans la limite de 3 mois pour
Saint-Martin voilà on interromp un
instant le suivi des travaux en séance
pour et bien ici une interview en salle
des conférences la salle des conférences
qui justoue l'hémicycle où se tiennent
ces débats j'accueille ici Patrick
canner bonjour vous êtes le président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat un mot sur le
début de la reprise après les questions
au Gouvernement vous avez fait un rappel
au règlement vous auriez souhaité que et
bien un ministre en particulier Éric
Dupont Moretti pour pas le nommé soit là
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a des mesures
qui et bien concernent directement son
ministère c'est ça effectivement nous
sommes en train d'étudier les articles
de bis et de terre qui concernent le
code de la nationalité d'ailleurs qui
n'a rien à faire là et le ministre
Darmanin a dit que on était sur les
cavaliers législatifs je dis simplement
que dans ce cadre on aurait aimé avoir
au banc le ministre compétent qui n'est
pas monsieur Darmanin euh je bien queur
Darmanin est compétent sur beaucoup de
choses dans ce texte mais ce n'est pas
monsieur Darmanin c'est Monsieur Dupont
Moretti et euh on a demandé dans le
cadre d'un article du règlement général
du Sénat le 446 pour être très précis on
l' demandé la réserve de ces articles
c'est-à-dire le déport en soirée on en
parle plus tard pour que le ministre
compétent soit au banc mais vous savez
que Éric Dupont Moretti est occupé il
est devant la Cour de Justice de la
République oui euh mais je pense qu'il
n'est plus devant la Cour de justice le
soir voilà donc vous savez nous on
travaille jusqu'à 1h du matin donc il
aurait pu venir à 22h 23h 24h on
l'aurait accueilli avec plaisir pour
parler de ce sujet même si je suis
convaincu qu'il aurait dit lui-même que
ce texte de l'article 2 et l'article 3
n'avait rien à faire euh dans le le le
projet général de ce projet de loi alors
allons justement sur ce volet de
l'intégration par le travail on devrait
attaquer ces mesures dans les toutes
prochaines heures toutes prochaines
minutes il y aura d'abord une petite
suspension de séance mais on va donc
aller dans le cœur de ce sujet d'
l'article 3 ces mesur des titres de
séjour dans les métiers en tension et
donc cette écriture qu'on trouvait les
sénateurs de la majorité sénatoriale la
droi du centre ensemble pour supprimer
l'article 3 et 4 et et cré un article
additionnel qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
cet accord qui a été annoncé hier vers
19h30 c'est une capitulation pour une
partie de la droite sénatoriale pour les
centristes disons-le clairement qui
avait imaginé par un amendement de
Monsieur Marseille le président du
groupe centriste de de permettre que cet
article 3 soit maintenu mais amender
avec peut-être le soutien de la gauche
sénatoriale l'amendement n'allait pas
assez loin selon nous donc nous
regrettons en fait que cet accord fasse
disparaître symboliquement l'article 3
l'article 4 pour aboutir finalement sans
le dire vraiment un article additionnel
qui va aboutir lui-même à
une minoration de la circulire Vals
durcissement de la circulaire Vals c'est
un durcissement mais je dirais c'est un
effaiblissement pour la République
durcissement de la circulaire mais
affaiblissement pour la valeur sociale
de la République
française nous nous disons simplement
que quand un immigré qui certes est en
situation irrégulière travaille a un
logement paye parfois ses impôts qu'il
puisse avoir un statut par le travail
nous paraissait normal c'était
l'équilibre souhaité par le gouvernement
et on a le sentiment aujourd'hui que
peut-être sous l'gide de Monsieur
Darmanin il y a un durcissement qui fait
bien plaisir à la droite sénatoriale
alors justement une dernière question
sur ce sujet avant de parler de l'aide
médicale d'État mais selon vous qui êtes
observateur ici au Sénat oui bien sûr
mais qui regardez ce qui se passe entre
gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale
c'est ce qu'on on comprend qu'est-ce qui
gagne en fait dans ce bras de faer entre
le gouvernement leslr ou les centristes
qu'est-ce qui a tiré son son épingle du
jeu qui est qui est l'idiot utile de
l'autre ou qui est la marionnette et le
marionnettiste c'est un peu la question
qui rorte une victoire politique c'est
pour moi une défaite pour le projet
initial c'est une défaite pour le projet
initial et il y a une recomposition de
la droite autour manifestement de
Monsieur Darmanin et de Monsieur
rotillot je crois que c'est ça le
message politique qui est visible
aujourd'hui au Sénat un dernier mot
rapidement si vous le voulez bien
Patrick canner puisque l'aide médicale
d'urgence a été transformé en aide
l'aide médicale d'État a été transformé
en aide médicale d'urgence par la droite
sénatoriale la droite et le centre hier
en séance une hérésie humanitaire
sanitaire et financière dénonce
aujourd'hui la Fédération des hôpitaux
publics pointant le risque de
conséquences dramatiques sur le système
de santé déjà en souffrance qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque la FHF a raison les
médecins ont aussi tous raison c'est une
aberration sociale c'est une aberration
sanitaire une aberration économique et
même éthique et donc nous avons combattu
cette suppression de la me nous sommes
très soutenus sur les positions que nous
avons tenu ce qui me fait bien plaisir
non pas pour nous-même mais pour
finalement une certaine idée là aussi de
la République sociale dans notre pays
que dire à tous les médecins qui
s'inquiètent notamment en milieu
hospitalier et bien il faut leur dire
que il y aura une deuxième lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale j'espère que le
gouvernement sera plus courageux plus
courage je qu'il ne l'a été puisque hier
le gouvernement aurait pu s'opposer
montrer sa volonté d'opposition il n'a
fait que demander la sagesse et c'est
donc pour moi de l'eau tiède et sur ce
type de sujet il ne faut pas avoir peur
et bien merci merci Patrick canner pour
cette interview en direct au micro de
Public Sénat on va retourner dans
l'hémicycle juste un mot pour vous dire
que dans les toutes prochaines minutes
il y aura une suspension de séance et
ensuite le Sénat va attaquer l'examen de
tout le chapitre 2 celui sur
l'intégration par le travail et Public
Sénat qui bouleverse son antenne pour
suivre tout cela en direct jusque très
tard ce soir de la
commission oui demande de retrait ou
défavorable puisqu'il s'agit d'un
rapport ceci étant il me semble chers
collègues que monsieur le ministre vous
a répondu par anticipation tout à
l'heure en vous disant qu'il
souhaiterait pouvoir avoir ce débat
devant l'Assemblée je précise également
puisque nous avions essayé
là suis dans les préoccupations de
conseil constitutionnel dans le
le 1 an 9 mois et 3 mois que j'aiévoqué
tout à l'heure on a essayé de s'adapter
à la situation migratoire et en
particulier pour maotte nous avons tenu
compte non pas du rapport d'information
mais de dués du rapport dans le cadre
d'une mission
d'information de notre collègue député
de maotte Madame Youssoufa qui a établi
un rapport sur cette question et c'est
un des éléments que l'on a qui avait
justifié l'amendement que nous vous
avons présenté il y a quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre sagesse si j'ai
bien compris sagesse monsieur bit vous
êtes sollicité pour un retrait par la
Commission on retire vous le gardez donc
je le mets au voix avec un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
l'adoption de cet amendement qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté monsieur Bitz vous nous présentez
le 480 ah non c'est Monsieur buis on
varie les plaisirs présidente dans son
avis du 5 juin 2018 sur la proposition
de loi de notre collègue tan Mohamed
soli tendant à adapté aux
caractéristiques et contraintes
particulières de maotte les règles
d'acquisition de la nationalité
française par une personne née en France
de parents étrangers le Conseil d'État
avait recommandé que soit menée une
campagne d'information à mayottte et
aussi à destination des pays d'origine
des personnes et immigrants
irrégulièrement sur l'état du droit qui
résulterait du vote de ce texte les
dispositions de cette PPL ont finalement
été intégrés dans la loi du 10 septembre
2018 pour une immigration maîtrisée un
droit d'asile effectif et une
intégration réussie la campagne
d'information n'a cependant jamais été
déployée par cet amendement nous
souhaitons demander au gouvernement
quelle suite il comp en donner à cette
préconisation indispensable nous
attirons également son attention sur la
nécessité d'agir préventivement pour
faire connaître l'état du droit aux
hommes femmes français ou étrangers en
situation régulière qui serait tenté de
reconnaître des enfants qui ne sont pas
les leurs nombreux sont ceux qui en
ignorent les risques pourtant
reconnaître un enfant au seul fin
d'obtenir un titre de séjour où la
nationalité française est actuellement
puni de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et de
15000 € d'amende 75000 € après
l'adoption de la présente loi par
ailleurs cette infraction entraîne des
conséquences patrimoniales importantes
puisqu'une contribution à l'éducation et
à l'entretien des enfants reconnus
pourrait être demandé par la mère et des
droits sur l'héritage pour être accordés
à des enfants il est bien sûr
indispensable d'accenter en naal la
lutte contre ces comportements
délictueux merci chers collègu avis de
la commission même avis qu'il y a
quelques secondes de retrait ou
défavorable très bien même avis de
sagesse du gouvernement même avis de
sagesse vous le retirez vous le
maintener donc je le mets au voie avec
un avis défavorable de la commission un
avis de sagesse du gouvernement qui est
pour l'adoption de cet amendement qui
est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté à l'article 2 terre nous sommes
saisis de trois amendements en
discussion commune un amendement 21
rectifié de madame la Présidente de
Monsieur Cabanel oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues cet amendement de notre
présidente Marie carè s'inscrit dans la
continuité de celui que nous avons
présenté tout à l'heure à l'article de
BIS cet article de terre prévoit
d'exclure les délinquants condamnés à
une peine d' moins 6 mois de prison du
bénéfice du droit du sol nous avons
trouvé absurde la condition d'une
manifestation de volonté nous croyons
cette fois que lorsqu'un mineur est
condamné à à la de la prison alors même
que celui-ci a grandi dans notre pays il
faut d'abord y voir peut-être une dé
faillance notre système éducatif au-delà
de la question du recul du droit du sol
à quoi nous sommes opposés nous sommes
également dérangés par cette exigence
morale à l'gard du mineur qui je crois
sont encore trop jeunes pour qu'on leur
refuse de commettre des erreurs il est
déraisonnable de vouloir conditionner à
ce point l'avenir d'un enfant la seule
nationalité de ses parents aussi nous
proposons comme pour l'article préc que
cette disposition soit supprimée de ce
projet de loi merci Monsieur Cabanel
pour l'amendement 237 monsieur Durin
merci madame la Présidente cet article
de terre aurait en effet pour priver un
mineur étranger né en France de parents
étrangers de l'accès de la nationalité
française sur le seul motif qu'il aura
été condamné à une peine égale ou
supérieure à 6 mois d'emprisonnement
alors nous trouvons que que cette mesure
est est évidemment tout à fait
disproportionné car elle a pour
conséquence de d'obturer définitivement
l'avenir d' un mineur étranger pour des
faits potentiellement de faible gravité
au seul prétexte que ses parents sont
étrangers cette mesure elle est
choquante aussi par son automaticité
l'absence de considération qu'elle
accorde à la personnalité du mineur et
puis c'est un renoncement comme l'a dit
notre collègue Cabanel la dimension
éducative à laquelle nous sommes très
attachés monsieur Durin monsieur
benaroche pour le même
amendement présidente euh c'est encore
un coup de canif pour pas dire de
couteau dans le pour pas dire plus
sur le droit du sol il y a un article du
du Code civil empêche l'acquisition de
la nationalité déjà pour toute personne
condamné à une peine égale ou supérieure
à 6 mois d'emprisonnement non assorti
d'une mesure de surcis mais cet article
prévoit néanmoins que cela ne s'applique
pas aux enfants ni de parents étrangers
qui obtiendrai la nationalité française
l'article que nous allons voter il faut
en être bien conscient enlève cette
exception aujourd'hui ce qui fait qu'on
pourra empêcher un enfant né sur le
territoire français et ayant vécu
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans parce qu'il a
été condamné à une peine de 6 mois de
présent d'acquérir cette nationalité à
jusqu'à la FA de sa vie il faut bien
peser
euh de quoi il s'agit n'est-ce pas
l'enfant de 16 ans qui serait condamné
par exemple on peut prendre des tas
d'exemples j'en ai pris un j'en ai pris
un dans le code hein pour agression
sonore à une peine parce que c'est c'est
c'est la peine qui est prévu de 6 mois
de prison ne pourrait plus c'est la
peine qui est prévue excusez-moi on fait
une loi on n'est pas là pour commenter
si les peines qui existent aujourd'hui
dans le code sont des peines qui sont
justifié ou pas on fait une loi en
fonction de ce qui existe il y a un code
civil qui dit des choses il me semble
qu'on est à la commission des lois et
que jusqu'à présent on a été sérieux
donc il est écrit aujourd'hui que c'est
une peine qui permet d'avoir 6 mois de
prison donc excusez-moi donc ça veut
dire que par cet amendement quelqu'un
qui serait condamné pour cette raisonlà
aujourd'hui sur le territoires français
à 6 mois de prison ne pourrait pas
acquérir de sa vie entière la
nationalité française alors qu'il était
mineur et qu'il a peut-être commis cette
peine alors qu'il avait 14 ou 15 ans
c'est tout il faut bien peser alors vous
pesez correctement je vous demande juste
de peser correctement vous pouvez le
vouloir nous ne sommes pas d'accord mais
je comprendrai que vous le vouliez je
vous dis simplement ayez conscience de
ce que vous avez àeser de ce que vous
décidez aujourd'hui merci Monsieur
benaroch avis de la commission sur ces
amendements
alors la commission est défavorable à
ses endements j'en donne rapidement
l'explication nous avions été convaincu
par l'amendement de Madame Boyer donc
nous suivons sur l'accord qui avait été
donné en commission tout simplement par
la question de la
gravité non monsieur bénaroche le le
texte qui a été adopté ne concerne pas
la peine
encourue mais bien la peine prononcé et
deuxièmement quand j'ai entendu il y a
quelques secondes l'indication suivant
laquelle c'était une faible gravité
monsieur Durin pour une un
emprisonnement de 6 mois tous les
praticiens il y en a quand même dans cet
hémicycle
d'éminent savent que prononcer une peine
ferme de 6 mois à l'égard d'un mineur on
n'est pas du tout sur des sujets d'une
faible gravité euh ce qui explique euh
les raisons pour laquell on a dé donné
ave un accord favorable et dernier
élément par rapport au derniers
intervenant de nos parmi nos collègues
euh Monsieur bénaroche Nous ne privons
pas l'adoption de le texte de la
Commission ne prive pas avis euh
l'intéressé de pouvoir demander sa
naturalisation simplement il ne
bénéficie pas de la naturalisation de
plein droit lié au droit du sol pour
reprendre mais il peut parfaitement être
amené à faire une demande de
naturalisation à postéorie donc ça ne
ferme pas la voix voilà les raisons pour
lesquelles nous avions été convaincus
par la position de Madame Boyer et les
raisons pour lesquelles nous avons donné
un avis nous vous donnons un avis
défavorable sur les trois amendements de
suppression merci monsieur le rapporteur
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre favorable favorable donc je
mets au voix ces
amendements pardon madame de La
Gonterie
simplement pourf on votera évidemment
ses amendements d'autant que l'un
d'entre
eux a été déposé par nous mais il faut
bien voir de quoi on parle hein alors
après on peut faire l'exégèse de la
peine encouru pas encouru prononcé et
cetera et cetera tout ça est tout ça est
juste mais on parle d'un enfant qui est
né en France et donc qui n'aurait pas la
nationalité française que
devient-il alors vous me direz ah bah la
belle affaire il aura la nationalité de
ses par très bien juridiquement c'est
exact mais enfin vraisemblablement exact
sauf que l'enfant donc a vécu depuis sa
naissance en France donc vous voyez un
petit peu le sujet c'est que donc on
contraindrait donc cet enfant qui n'a
jamais mis les pieds ailleurs que dans
le pays où il est né avoir une
nationalité d'un pays qu'il ne connaît
pas je livre ça votre
réflexion ça arrive monsieur
benaroch
oui merci je voulais rassurer Monsieur
boncarer Je je connais très bien la
différence entre les peines encourues et
les peines simplement je vous dis c'est
une peine encourue donc elle peut être
prononcée donc quand nous faisonsut re
prononcé donc à partir du moment où nous
faisons une loi monsieur vcer nous
disons la condamnation de si mois
empêche l'application du droit du sol ça
veut dire qu'effectivement toutes les
infractions toutes les toutes les
condamnations possible à des peines de 6
mois si elles sont prononcées empêche le
droit du sol la deuxième chose Monsieur
bcarer Madame de La gter l' l'a très
bien
dit que faisons-nous aujourd'hui de tous
ces enfants puisqu'il s'agit d'enfants
nous sommes bien d'accord ils ont moins
de 18 ans que faisons-nous aujourd'hui
de tous ces enfants qui ont vécu toute
leur vie en France je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure aussi sur la demande volontaire
de nationalité que faisons-nous de tous
ces enfants qui ont passé toute leur vie
en France qui sont nés qui ont vécu qui
ont eu toutes leurs activités qui ont
été éduqués qui ont été formés que
faisons nous deux quelle est la
nationalité à laquelle ils auront droit
est-ce qu'en fait le but est simplement
de créer une complication supplémentaire
à l'accès à la nationalité je
comprendrai très bien que vous
l'exprimez comme ça voilà nous
souhaitonsnous faire en sorte que
l'accès à la nationalité française
devienne de plus en plus compliqué bon
encore une fois c'est votre position i
je veux bien l'accepter on en discute
mais ne nous cachons pas derrière un
certaindment aussi bien dans la
discussion d'hier sur la me que dans
celle-ci pour ne pas exprimer la réalité
qui est que vous souhaitez rendre de
plus en plus compliqué l'accès à la
nationalité française merci Monsieur
benaroche monsieur spiner
oui madame la Présidente je suis très
étonné parce que il y a des gens qui
vivent dans les codes et il y a des gens
qui vivent dans la vie réelle si vous
allez interroger les magistrats et les
parquetiers des tribunau pour enfant si
à 16 ans vous êtes condamné à 6 mois
fermes je peux vous dire que ça doit
être au moins la 6e ou 7e comparution
devant le juge des enfants parce qu'en
général ça commence par le rappel à la
loi la remise aux parents
l'avertissement j'ai d'ailleurs toujours
été étonné que la remise aux parents
soit considérée comme une peine et je
referme la parenthèse mais donc si mois
ferme c'est une grosse peine alors vous
pouvez pour essayer de dire ah les
nuisances sonores et cetera mais c'est
une plaisanterie quand on prend 6 mois
fermes c'est qu'on a commis des faits
graves lorsqu'on est mineur la deuxième
chose que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que les magistrats seront parfaitement
conscients que s'ils prononcent une
peine de 6 mois fermes ils mettront le
mineur dans la situation de se voir
refuser sa nationalité et faites aussi
confiance au magistrat de ne pas
distribuer ses peines à la légère quand
ils en connaîtront l'enjeu après sur le
fait de dire que c'est des enfants je
m'étonne quand sur certains ban en prent
la majorité à 16 ans que brusquement les
adultes de demain soient les enfants
d'hier il faut être quand même un peu
cohérent voilà merci Monsieur spinner je
vais donc mettre au voix ces amendements
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est qui est pour
l'adoption de ces
amendements qui est
contre ils ne sont donc pas adoptés qui
s'abstient ils ne sont donc pas adoptés
té je mets au voix pardon l'article 2
ter qui est pour l'adoption de cet
article qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté après l'article 2 ter nous
avons un amendement 121 présenté par
Monsieur
surek merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame monsieur le
rapporteur notre amendement a pour but
de supprimer tous les articles de notre
législation qui consacrent dans le droit
positif le droit du sol ou le double
droit du sol la réflexion sur la
question de la nationalité est
essentielle pour notre pays la
nationalité est un pilier fondamental de
l'identité de notre nation et il est
impératif que notre législation reflète
les valeurs et les intérêts de la France
être français sit tout ce mérite ainsi
l'amendement que nous discutons
aujourd'hui est une première étape vers
l'alignement de notre législation sur
cette vision le droit du sol tel qu'il
est actuellement consacré accorde
automatiquement à sa majorité la
nationalité française à toute personne
né sur le territoire français quels que
soient ses antécédents familiaux de même
le dou ble droit du sol permet à un
enfant né de en France et de parents
étrangers d'acquérir automatiquement la
nationalité française bien que ces
principes et leur légitimité il doivent
être revu pour s'assurer qu'il
correspondent aux intérêts et aux
valeurs de notre nation la réforme
constitutionnelle proposée durant la
campagne présidentielle par Marine Le
Pen a pour objectif de redéfinir les
critères de la nationalité française
notamment en établissant des conditions
plus strictes pour son acquisition dans
cette obtique il est logique de
commencer dès maintenant à supprimer les
dispositions législatives qui s'opposent
à cette vision en éliminant les les
articles de notre législation consacrant
le droit du sol et le double droit du
sol nous envoyons un signal fort
indiquant que la nationalité française
ne peut être octoyée automatiquement
mais doit être gagné par des actes et
des engagements envers notre nation
cette démarche vise à assurer que la
nationalité française est un privilège
réserver à ceux qui en partagent les
valeurs et souhaitent sincèrement
contribuer à la prospérité et à l'unité
de notre nation je vous remercie merci
avis de la commission sur cet
amendement merci madame le Président
l'avis de la commission est est
défavorable nous avons tout à l'heure un
un débat bref mais intense sur l'origine
du droit du sol et on voit
qu'effectivement tout peut-être discuté
y compris jusqu'à l'histoire du droit du
sol mais il nous semble difficile tout
de même de le supprimer au détour d'un
amendement et ce d'autant plus que nous
avons déjà pours poursuivi dans ce débat
quelques aménagements qui nous
apparaissent suffisants à l'état très
bien vie du
gouvernement défavorable défavorable
très bien je mets au voix cette am
amement 121 avec un double avis
défavorable qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté amendement 573 présenté par
Monsieur benaroche
oui madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement de Monique de Marco
amendement d'appel en 1999 le
législateur a introduit une nouvelle
disposition dans le Code civil visant à
permettre au ministre de la Défense
d'octroyer la nationalité française à
toute personne étrangère engagé dans les
armées françaises qui a été blessé en
mission en cours ou à l'occasion d'un
engagement opérationnel et qui en fait
la demande ou en cas de décès à ses
enfants cette disposition illustr une
réalité de nombreux étrangers vent
cotidiennement au service de la France
sous les drapeaux mais aussi dans la vie
civile il existe ainsi pour le
gouvernement diverses dispositions
juridique pour octroyer la nationalité
française à des personnalités étrangères
qui contribuent au rayonnement la France
sans contrôle du Parlement d'ailleurs
sur ses naturalisations et dans
l'opportunité quelquefois peut paraître
étonnante ce choix de naturalisation ces
choix de naturalisation du des du
gouvernement traduisent une certaine
vision de la nationalité française qui
en fait dans ce cas-là relève du fait du
presse s'ils sont confiés au seul
membrre du gouvernement les
parlementaires que nous sommes euh sont
des interlocuteur privilégiés de tous
les élus sur notre territoire national
et nous sommes tous les premiers témoins
de l'intégration de personnes étrangèr
dans la vie de la cité personnes
étrangères qui accompliraient un certain
nombre de missions pour notre pays il
représente tous nous tous et tous ces
étrangers une certaine idée de la France
c'est pourquoi cet amendement propose
d'étendre au parlementaires la
prérogative d'un droit de naturalisation
exceptionnel
monsieur bonaroche avis de la commission
l'avis de la commission madame la
Présidente est de de relever que il est
déjà possible mais monsieur baroch ne
l'ignore pas il a dit de naturaliser une
personne étrangère pour service
exceptionnel rendu à la nation il est
tout à fait loisible à un parlementaire
de proposer une candidature de la même
façon que nous pouvons proposer des
candidatures pour des décorations que
nous ne décernons pas nous-même donc
c'est un avis de de retrait ou
défavorable déforable défavorable pour
le gouvernement vous êtes sollicité pour
un retrait monsieur Baroche vous
maintenez vous maintenez donc nous
mettons au voie cet amendement avec deux
avis défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté nous avons ensuite
deux amendements identiques le premier
le 346 présenté par Madame Boyer merci
madame la Présidente le présent
amendement t à allongé le délai de
résidence terme duquel la naturalisation
peut-être accordée à l'étranger résidant
habituellement en France alors que ce
délai de résidence est d'aujourd'hui de
5 ans il serait ainsi porté à 10 ans il
convient de renforcer l'appréciation de
la réalité des liens que l'étranger
concerné entretient avec la France avant
de procéder à sa naturalisation le délai
de 10 ans correspond de surcroix au
délai de validité d'une carte de
résident et présenterait ainsi
l'avantage d'une meilleure cohérence
pour certains parcours comme ça a été
rappelé hier par exemple cette durée
minimale est aussi de 10 ans en Autriche
en Espagne en Lituanie en Pologne en
Slovénie et en Italie elle est de 9 ans
au Danemarc de 8 ans en Croatie Estonie
Hongrie Roumanie Slovaquie et Allemagne
et de 7 ans à Chypre et en Grèce une
fois encore nous voyons bien que la
comparaison européenne révèle que la
France est la plus généreuse allons-nous
dire dans sa politique d'immigration
légale que la plupart de ces pays
voisins et amis en France les exigences
en terme d'intégration bah sont aussi
elles particulièrement généreuses ou ou
certains considéreront qu'elles sont
faibles le regroupement familial et
l'accès à la nationalité répondent à des
règles souvent beaucoup moins strictes
que ses voisins européens de plus les
personnes étrangères en France font
l'objet d'un accueil incomparablement
plus généreux que partout ailleurs qu'il
s'agisse des réfugiés des demandeurs
d'asile des mineurs isolés ou encore des
étrangers en situation irrégulière je je
vous remerci merci Madame Boyer le 521
monsieur ravier il est défendu
[Musique]
non merci madame la Présidente en 2022
59900 des acquisitions de nationalité
française le sont par naturalisation au
recensement 2021 l'INS estime à 4500000
le nombre d'immigrés légaux en France
c'est-à-dire d'étrangers nés hors de
France dont une partie très importante
et où restera au moins 5 ans sur notre
sol et pourra prétendre obtenir la
nationalité française or la nationalité
française ça se mérite ce n'est pas un
droit universel ce n'est pas un bout de
papier ce n'est pas une carte
d'allocation ce n'est pas un titre de
séjour à durée indéterminée la
nationalité française c'est ce que nous
avons de plus précieux la nationalité
française n'est pas simplement une
fiction juridique c'est un enracinement
de l'âme c'est un héritage un lien une
communauté de destin à cela on ne peut
prétendre la légère c'est pourquoi le
critère de résidence de 5 ans n'apparaît
pas suffisant de même qu'on peut
assimiler des individus mais pas des
masses on peut assimiler sur le temps
long mais pas dans la précipitation vous
rendez-vous compte que de ce que le
droit dit en réalité une personne
immigrée qui est arrivé au début du
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron aurait pu
être naturalisé l'année dernière c'est
quand même trop rapide même si 5 ans
avec Emmanuel Macron c'est long c'est
très très long je vous l'accorde en
faisant cela on ne fait qu'argum menter
qu'augmenter pardon la crise civique et
la fracture de la société c'est nier ce
qui'est la France nier ce que veut dire
être français il faut mettre un terme à
la déconstruction juridique des mots et
du sens des choses car oui il y a une
culture et une identité française ceux
qui disent le contraire participe au
wisme qui ronge notre état et notre
civilisation c'est pourquoi cet
amendement allonge le temps de résidence
habituelle minimum pour accéder à la
nationalité française à 10 ans c'est
tout à fait faisable les européens sont
bien plus exigeents que le que le nôtre
la Bulgarie la République tchèque
l'Italie Lituanie l'Espagne la Suisse
ont un délai minimum de 10 ans chers
collègues à l'heure où le processus de
de décivilisation et de désassimilation
ouf sont à l'œuvre sur notre sol je vous
invite à prendre vos responsabilités
elles sont historiques merci Monsieur
ravier avis de la commission sur ces
deux amendements
identiques merci madame le
Président la Commission a été assez
convaincue par l'argument qui a été
développé par Madame qui consistant à
dire que le D 10 an qui est égal au
délai de de de la carte de de validité
de la carte de résident était un délai
qui permettait de passer de
l'intégration à l'assimilation et donc
de pouvoir obtenir une naturalisation
c'est donc un avis
favorableable monsieur le ministre avis
du
gouvernement défavorable très bien avis
défavorable donc je mets au voix cet
madame pardon madame Narin oui merci
madame la Présidente je voulais juste
souligner mon désarroi face à cet avis
favorable de la commission sur deux
amendements qui sont identiques euh
entre déposé par la droite à les
républicains et le rassemblement
national même non même pas le
rassemblement national reconquête
l'extrême droite de Monsieur ravier on
voit bien la dérive malheureusement dans
laquelle s'est engagé cette assemblée
dans ce projet de loi immigration où là
encore on traite du droit de nationalité
qui n'a rien à voir pour rendre la
France de moins en moins
accueillante vis-à-vis de ceux qui
peuvent veulent devenir Français merci
monsieur
benaroche madame la
Présidente je remarque que pour la
deuxième fois puisque ça s'est déjà
produit hier sur un amendement qui a été
voté d'ailleurs mais on cite toujours
Valérie Boyer mais on site jamais
reconquête donc en fait là c'est la même
chose pour la deuxème fois c'est pas la
première dans ce débatlà ça sera la
deuxème fois qu'un amendement à
l'identique avec des défenses très
similaire madame la rapporteur euh en
quelque sorte on pourrait considérer que
les républicains sont à la reconquête
euh d'une absence de générosité de notre
pays puisque si j'ai bien compris en
fait il y a pas besoin d'appel d'air
supplémentaire qui serait créé par une
mesure ou par une autre puisque ça fait
des années que nous sommes un appel
d'air perpétuel France je m'étonne même
que tous les chiffres monent que nous ne
sommes pas le pays qui accueille le plus
d'immigrés je m'en étonne puis tous les
appels d' cré sur la générosité que nous
avons à tous les niveaux sur la
naturalisation sur la nationalité
française sur le traitement des
travailleurs immigrés sur les
prestations que nous leur donnons sur
les salaires que nous leur affectons je
me demande aujourd'hui encore pourquoi
effectivement nous ne sommes pas le pays
en Europe et dans le monde qui accueill
le plus d'immigrés parce que cet
argument ne tient pas parce que cet
argument n'a jamais été réel parce que
c'est une fable que nous racontons parce
que tous les chiffres qui sont donnés y
compris par tous les
sociologu statisticiens y compris
gouvernementaux syndicalistes nous
montrre que ces chiffres-là montrent
bien qu'il n'y a pas d'appel d'air et
que nous ne sommes pas le pays le plus
généreux qui accueille des milliers de
d'immigrants supplémentaires par rapport
aux autres donc arrêtant d'utiliser cet
argument pour défendre tout y compris
pour le fait que maintenant il faudrait
10 ans sur le territoire français au
lieu de 5 ans pour pouvoir prétendre à
une naturalisation parce que 5 ans n'est
pas suffisant dites-vous et pourquoi pas
25 ans ou pourquoi pas toute une vie
après tout merci Monsieur Barroche
madame la rapporteur vous avez souhaité
reprendre la parole j'ai souhaité
reprendre la parole pour répondre au
désarois de mes collègues qui s'affolent
de ce que un amendement qui émane des
républicains puisse être similaire à un
amendement qui émane de Monsieur ravier
je voudrais vous dire d'abord que la
pensée politique ne doit pas s'articuler
pour ou contre la pensée politique d'une
are autre personne ou d'un autre
mouvement politique et chacun pense bien
ce qu'il entend et d'ailleurs j'ai
observé que en début de séance le groupe
socialiste avait déposé un amendement
qui s'est révélé tout à fait similaire à
un autre amendement de Monsieur ravier
c'est-à-dire que vous pensiez exactement
la même chose sauf que vous définissez
votre pensée politique par rapport à
celle de Monsieur ravier et quand vous
vous êtes rendu compte non cétait pas
une demande de rapport madame de La
Gonterie lorsque vous êtes rendu compte
que vous pensiez la même chose vous avez
tirer votre amendement vous en avez
parfaitement le droit mais arrêtons de
penser qu'il y a des choses que nous
avons le droit de faire parce qu'elles
ne sont pas similaires à des
comportement d'autres groupes politiques
et qu'il y a des choses que nous n'ons
pas de droit de faire chacun fait ce
qu'il entend en fonction de sa propre
pensée très bien je vais donc mettre au
voix ces deux amendements qui ont reçu
un avis favorable de la commission un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour l'adoption de cet amendement de ces
amendements
qui est
contre qui s'abstient ils sont donc
adoptés je pense qu'il fautter ah pardon
on me dit que il faut recompter donc je
remets au voix pour plus de sécurité je
remets au voix pour plus de sécurité
donc qui est pour l'adoption de ces
amendements 5 7 18 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 2 21 29 23 24 25 26 27 28 299
30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 39 40 42 43 44
45 46 47 48
48 alors alors 45 qui est
contre 8 10 12 14 16 18 20 22 24
l'amendement est donc adopté je le
confirme
voilà nous avons ensuite l'amendement
122 qui est présenté par Monsieur
Zurek non c'est Monsieur auchard Merci
beaucoup Mad la Présidente c'est Mo qui
le présente merci madame la présidente
madame monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le ministre notre amendement vise à
supprimer la bille ou la
multinationalité la question de la bille
ou la multinationalité est en effet
complexe qui appelle une réponse
pragmatique d'un côté il est important
de reconnaître que de nombreuses
personnes peuvent avoir des liens
culturels familiaux ou professionnels
avec plus d'un pays cependant la bille
ou la multinationalité peut aussi
soulever des questions de loyauté et de
cohésion nationale commment on attest
ces événements récents qu' traverser
notre pays l'amendement que nous
défendons pose ainsi une approche
équilibrée il suggère la suppression de
laabille ou de la multinationalité en
tant que principe général ce qui
permettrait de clarifier les obligations
et les droits des citoyens
français cela contribuerait à renforcer
le lien entre la nationalité la loyauté
envers la France nous défendons depuis
toujours le principe de l'assimilation
acquirir la nationalité française c'est
épouser les valeurs et l'histoire
française devenir français c'est un acte
d'amour et comme tout acte d'amour il
paraît légitime qu'il soit unique faire
nation est un plébiscite de tous les
jours et s'il désire d'un étranger et de
devenir français il serait anormal qu'il
conserve la nationalité du pays qu'il a
volontairement voulu quitter cependant
not proposition est fondé sous le signe
du pragmatisme en effet elle intègre la
possibilité d'accords bilatéraux
négociés au cas par cas à avec des pays
ayant de forts liens amicaux et anciens
avec la France la possibilité de
dérogation par le biais d'accords
bilatéraux offre une approche adaptée au
réalité du monde d'aujourd'hui où de
nombreuses personnes ont des liens
transnationaux c'est aussi pourquoi nous
défendons avec vigueur le principe de
suppression de la binationalité tout en
laissant nos services diplomatiques
malmener d'ailleurs depuis 6 ans le soin
de construire des accords au cas par cas
selon les intérêts de la France merci je
vous merci avis de la
commission merci madame le Président je
pense que cet amendement est un
amendement d'appel et que nos collègues
ne croi pas raisonnablement que nous
puissions au détour d'un simple
amendement et sans véritable débat
supprimer la BI ou la multinationalité
quel que soi les questions qu'elle
puisse poser c'est donc une demande de
rentrée ou un avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement même avis défavorable vous
êtes sollicité pour un retrait monsieur
auchard monsieur auchard un retrait non
on met au voix donc je mets au voix
l'amendement 122 avec un double
défavorable commission et gouvernement
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
avons ensuite deux amendements
identiques monsieur pas identi mais en
discussion commune monsieur ravier
pouvez présenter les deux
peut-être 527 et
525 vous nêtes pas obligé de prendre les
4 minutes monsieur allez plus
sérieusement donc l'amendement
je vais vous prendre un exemple concret
de l'effet de cet amendement si comme
l'affirme monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur Karim Benzema au sujet
duquel plusieurs journalistes affirment
qu'il a bien la double nationalité
franco-algérienne est en lien avec les
Frères musulmans je demande des
sanctions notamment sa déchéance de
nationalité rappelons-le comme
l'explique Florence Bergeot blquer
anthropologue au CNRS le frérisme est un
mouvement politico-religieux qui s'est
donné pour mission d'organiser la marche
de tous les musulmans vers le même
objectif l'instauration de la société
islamique mondiale si les propos du
ministre de l'intérieur sont avérés nous
devons envisager des sanctions contre
Karim Benzema nous devons demander la
déchéance de nationalité nous ne pouvons
accepter qu'un binational français
internationalement connu peut puisse
déshonorer et même trahir ainsi notre
pays cet amendement vise à déchoir tous
les bisationaux fussent-il nés français
de leur nationalité s'ils affichent
clairement une allégeance habituelle et
manifeste à une autre nation contre la
France son peuple et ses règles mais
puisqu'il faut rendre à César ce qui est
à César je rendrai à Madame Boyer à
notre excellente collègue madame Boyer
ce qui lui appartient ce qui lui
appartient ce que je viens de dire lui
appartient totalement donc chers
collègues de droite soutenez avec moi
Madame Boyer et voter cet amendement
pour que tous ceux qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont français que de papier puissent
être déchu monsieur Benzema comme les
autres et le 525 dit la même chose c'est
la même chose en d'autres termes en
d'autres termes être français se mérite
ou sérite quel est le mérite accompli
par un étranger fait français qui commet
un crime ou un délit en France pour
quelle grande raison devrait-on le
conserver au sein de la communauté
nationale on sait qu'à Marseille et
c'est les chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur 55 % des crimes et dél sont
commis par des étrangers 50 % au niveau
national 25 % des prisonniers de France
sont étrangers malheureusement on ne
compte pas les binationaux même la celh
en 2020 a validé le principe de la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
terroristes il est urgent d'étendre ce
principe à ceux qui terrorisent les
Français au quotidien qui leur rendent
la vie impossible en tuant pillant en
frappant en dilant en violant en volant
nos compatriotes je m'en remets au man
de Robert bandenter apprécié sur ces ban
qui lui aussi avait défendu la déchéance
de nationalité pour les terroristes
les terroristes du quotidien ne le sont
pas moins que les islamistes à Marseille
les narcoterroristes qui terrorisent des
honnêtes gens des quartier entier au
quotidien et
qui tue aussi des innocents des
innocents que l'on appelle honteusement
des victimes collatéral parmi vous ici
personne ne serait particulièrement
heureux de ne pas faire de ne pas faire
partie de la même communauté nationale
qu'un criminel ou ou connu ou reconnu la
nation est une famille on n'est pas tenu
de garder à nos côté les pièces
rapportées qui déchirent notre contrat
social et moral notre pacte civil notre
fraternité notre identité notre
réputation vous savez qui a inventé le
principe de la déchéance de la
nationalité un certain Raymond Point
Carré en 1927 vous savez qui était son
ministre de l'Intérieur un certain
Albert sarot radical socialiste et vous
savez qui a inventé le principe de la
déchéance de nationalité par pour les
naturalisés français qui ont commis un
crime ou un délit un certain Édouard
aladier président du en 1938 dont le
ministre de l'intérieur n'était tte
qu'Albert sarot vive le Parti radical
socialiste don je dois être un des
derniers représentants merci Monsieur
ravier je demande l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux
amendements l'avis de la commission sera
similaire à celui qui l' a été sur les
amendements précédents c'est-à-dire un
avis défavorable puisque encore une fois
nous n'allons pas modifier aussi
lourdement le droit de la nationalité au
détour d'un amendement pas plus que nous
ne ferons la déchance de nationalité une
p complémentaire c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci Madame la rapporteur
même avis monsieur le ministre même avis
du gouvernement je mets au voix ces deux
amendement d'abord l'amendement 527 qui
a recueilli deux avis défavorables qui
est pour son adoption qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 525
même
vote même vote il n'est pas adopté nous
avons ensuite un amendement 355 de
Madame
Siou
oui madame la Présidente cet amendement
a pour objet de relever le niveau du
droit de timbre qui est à l'heure
actuelle de 55 € pour le passer à 250 €
ce qui fera qu'il sera équivalent à ce
qui est demandé dans les pays européens
auxquels il est normal de se comparer et
qu'il se rapprochera des tarifs habituel
pour les demandes usuelles de documents
officiels merci Madame surtout avis de
la commission
merci madame le Président il est exact
c'est un montant qui qui n'a pas évolué
depuis 2011 qui n'est pas extrêmement
élevé c'est un avis de sagesse sagesse
avis du
gouvernement favorable défavorable
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre je mets
au voix cet amendement 355 qui a
recueilli un avis de sagesse de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour son
adoption
levez bien la main s'il vous
plaît voilà qui est
contre alors attendez je vais je vais
s'il vous plaît recommencer pour compter
donc je vous demander de lever la main
si vous êtes pour l'adoption de cet
amendement
15 2 28 2 32 33 34 35 36 37 38
39 20 21
22 43 40 avec les deux 43 ok qui est
contre
il
qui
s'abstient l'amendement est
adopté monsieur le Président je crois
que vous avez demandé une suspension de
séance il pouvez nous donner quelques
éléments à l'heure que la commission des
lois besoin de se réunir pour étudier
les sousamendements qui ont été déposés
postérieurement à la réunion de ce matin
salmonnerie pour 15 minutes 15 minutes
la séance est donc suspendue pour 15
minutes voilà il est 18h20 nous sommes
en direct sur l'antenne 2 Public Sénat
pour ne rien rater de l'examen du projet
de loi immigration le 3è jour de
l'examen de ce texte au Sénat le Sénat
qui est la première des deux chambres à
s'emparer du texte et dans quelques
minutes après cette suspension de 15
minutes et bien on va attaquer le volet
qui concerne l'article 3 l'intégration
par le travail et ses titres de séjour
un mot quand même pour mentionner ce
qu'on vient de vivre sur l'antenne
depuis la séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement puisqu'on a
terminé terer l'examen d'une série de
mesures ajouté par la droite et le
centre au Sénat donc des mesures sur le
droit du sol sur les questions
d'acquisition de la citoyenneté le Sénat
qui a adopté deux mesures principales
que l'on a retenu l'article 2 bis qui
est donc un nouvel article ajouté par le
Sénat qui vise à revenir sur
l'automaticité de l'acquisition de la
nationalité française pour les enfants
nés de parents étrangers ces enfants
entre 16 et 18 ans devront désormais
manifester la volonté de d'acquérir la
nationalité française autre ajout c'est
l'article 2 terre et lui il prive un
mineur de l'automaticité de
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française s'il a été condamné à une
peine d'au moins 6 mois de prison ferme
mais je vous le disais l'actualité
principale l'actualité brûlante de cette
soirée que vous allez vivre sur Public
Sénat en direct et en intégralité c'est
l'examen du chapitre 2 du projet de loi
immigration qui concerne et bien euh qui
concerne l'intégration par le travail
avec l'article 3 l'article totem comme
l'ont dit depuis plusieurs semaines
celui sur des titres de séjour dans les
métiers en tenstion on a appris hier
vers 19h30 que la majorité sénatoriale
après des mois de désaccord politique
sur cet article 3 avait finalement
trouvé un accord et c'est ça qui va se
jouer dans les prochaines minutes pour
en parler on va rejoindre notre
journaliste politique et parlementaire
en tribune de presse du Sénat Mathias
Arz c'est vous qui m'accompagnez tous
cet après-midi toute cette soirée pour
tout comprendre vous vous ne ratez rien
depuis la tribune de presse alors
qu'est-ce qui se joue exactement avec
cet accord entre LR et centriste écoutez
vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué Quentin
c'était le rebrondissement de la soirée
hier les républicains et les centristes
se sont accordés pour faire tomber les
articles 3 et 4 de ce texte immigration
un accord marqué du saut de la majorité
sénatoriale et pacté en début de soirée
un accord évidemment qui satisfait l'un
des sénateurs les plus fermement opposés
à la à la régularisation des sans
papiers je parle vous vous en doutez de
Bruno rotillo il était tout à l'heure au
micro d'Alexandre Poussard je vous
propose d'écouter sa réaction on aura
notre texte au départ le texte de
Monsieur Darmanin c'était un texte ferme
sur des points et l'xiste sur d'autres
un texte de l'EN même temps 24 27
articles il en aura plus de deux fois
tuls ce sera donc notre texte on aura
totalement bouleverser et transformer le
texte initial ce sera vraiment le texte
de la majorité sénatoriale et vous voyez
j'en suis très heureux parce que il y a
quelques jours j'aurais pas pu le parier
et pour et pour un mariage Quentin vous
le savez il faut être deux hein on
savait Hervé Marseille très attaché à
cet article 3 qui prévoit la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier il semble tout de même y trouvit
son compte le patron des des centristes
ici au Sénat il était également au micro
d'Alexandre Poussard
on a eu la même position depuis le mois
de février 98 % du texte a été voté en
mars et nous avions cette position il
fallait une accroche dans la loi bon euh
c'est ce qu'on a réussi à obtenir après
nos collègues LR ont voulu muscler sur
la ligne qui était là l'URE le texte
mais vous prenez mon amendement et vous
avez l'essentiel de ce qu'on a voté donc
voilà je pense que l'essentiel cétait
c'est surtout qu'il y a un texte qui
sorte du Sénat ce qu'ont obtenu les
centristes Quentin c'est un durcissement
de la circulaire Vals en deux mots cette
circulaire c'est la circulaire qui
réserve au préfets Laib la possibilité
de régulariser des travailleurs alors
les préfets seront à présent appelés
cette fois à prendre en compte outre la
réalité et la nature des activités
professionnelles de l'étranger son
insertion sociale et familiale son
respect de l'ordre républicain son
intégration à la siété française et
enfin son adhésion au mode de vie et aux
valeurs de celle-ci et bien merci
Mathias merci pour toutes ces
explications très précise et c'est le
débat qui va s'ouvr s'ouvrir dans les
prochaines minutes après cette
suspension de séance qui est en cours à
l'heure où l'on se parle il y aura donc
à priori dans les prochaines minutes la
suppression de l'article 3 sur les
titres de séjour dans les métiers en
tenstion également la suppression d'un
autre article article 4 qui vise à
faciliter l'accès à un travail pour
certains demandeurs d'asile et ensuite
il y aura l'examen d'un article
additionnel qui est donc cet accord
trouvé entre LR et centriste pour en
parler j'accueille ici Rémy Ferraud
bonjour monsieur Ferraud vous êtes
sénateur PS de Paris on vient d'entendre
avec Mathias Arz Bruno rotaillot dire on
aura notre texte et se féliciter de cet
accord trouvé avec les alliés centriste
hier votre réaction ça veut dire que
c'est un scénario catastrophe pour tous
ceux qui espéraient que ce texte puisse
au moins comporter des mesures qui
soient favorables à l'intégration et
notamment l'intégration par le travail
cela permet d'offrir des perspectives à
celles et ceux qui sont dans notre pays
soit qui travaillent tout en étant en
situation régulière parfois depuis de
nombreuses années soit aux demandeurs
d'asile qui n'ont pas envie de vivre
seulement de l'assistance mais aussi de
pouvoir travailler donc nous allons voir
parce que il y a beaucoup de
tractations qui se font en dehors de
l'hémicycle il faut qu'on voit ce qu'il
le reste mais je crains que ce soit ce
que dit Bruno retaillot qui soit juste
et non pas ce que dit Olivier dusopte
qui aura perdu tous ses arbitrages si
cela se confirme oui c'est cela le
gouvernement qui a présenté ce projet de
loi il y a maintenant 1 an en parlant
d'un texte équilibré vous le disiez
entre Olivier dusopte le ministre du
Travail et géralde Darmanin le ministre
de l'Intérieur entre ce volet et fermeté
dans la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale et aussi intégration par le
travail vous le dites le texte vient de
changer complètement va changer dans les
prochaines minutes complètement
d'équilibre ce n'est pas d'ailleurs
surprenant puisque de toute façon toutes
les main tendues du gouvernement sont à
la droite républicains qui sont sur une
position de plus en plus dur et qui se
rapproche de ce qu'a toujours porté le
Front national M s'il n'a plus
aujourd'hui ce nom-l que nous abordions
la gauche nous sommes pas à la fin du
processus mais à ce texte avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude et puis aussi quelques
espoirs nos espoirs sont en train d'être
douchés et nos inquiétudes étaient
sont est encore plus forte puisque la
droite a supprimé la me avec une forme
de bienveillance du gouvernement et
cetera donc c'est ce que j'app appelle
là le scénario catastrophe mais voilà la
discussion parlementaire n'est pas au
bout bien entendu d'ailleurs elle
s'ouvre mais on comprend que la droite
et le centre étant majoritaire s'ils ont
trouvé un accord c'est maintenant et
bien ce qui peut se dérouler très
logiquement dans les prochaines minutes
un mot quand même sur sur ce qui va se
jouer parce que on a compris suppression
de l'article 3 suppression de l'article
4 qui créa donc ces titres de séjour et
à la place un article additionnel qui a
été présenté en commission ce matin qui
va être débattu dans les prochaines
minutes et qui vise à durcir la
circulaire de d'un ministre socialiste
de l'Intérieur manuel Vals de 2012 avec
des conditions supplémentaires lorsque
le préfet voudra donner des titres de
séjour ça veut dire que même en droit
constant là il y a des choses qui vont
se passer sur le code des pour les
étrangers probablement et de manière
négative comme vous le dites
contrairement à ce que dit Olivier dusop
je crois sur votre antenne tout à
l'heure la circulaire Vals ça n'était
qu'une circulaire nous voulions
justement l'inscrire et nous voulons
toujours l'inscrire dans la la loi c'est
aussi ce à quoi s'était engagé le
gouvernement donc celui qui renonce à
toutes les mesures plus progressistes
qui permettaient un éventuel équilibre
du texte et bien c'est le gouvernement
qui renonce donc c'est lui qui est
aujourd'hui en position de faiblesse
c'est ce qui par exemple hier conduit à
donner un avis de sagesse c'est-à-dire
un avis de lâcheté sur la suppression de
laame pour le Sénat c'est visiblement en
train peut-être de se reproduire sur la
possibilité de régulariser les
travailleurs alors justement un mot sur
l'aide médicale d'État puisque c'est
l'une des mesures adoptées hier en
séance elle est remplacée par une aide
médicale d'urgence ça signifie que et
bien ce ne sont pas tous les soins qui
seront concernés pour les personnes sans
papier mais uniquement un certain nombre
restreint de soins qui pourront être
voilà comme cela dotés pour les
personnes sans papier qu'est-ce que ça
vous évoque on a vu la Fédération des
hôpitaux public qui parle d'une hérésie
humanitaire sanitaire et financière
aujourd'hui vous ne trouverez pas un
seul profè professionnel de santé pour
soutenir cette mesure c'est une mesure
qui est contraire à une forme d'humanité
et puis c'est aussi une mesure qui est
contraire à la santé publique c'est une
mesure qui est contraire à l'intérêt
national à l'intérêt des Français
eux-mêmes on l'a vu nous avons traversé
l'épidémie de covid donc c'est une
mesure qui est abérrante qui est
contraire à l'intérêt général mais qui
montre une posture idéologique et le
gouvernement ne s'est pas opposé à cette
posture idéologique nous verrons ce
qu'il fera à l'Assemblée nationale quand
le texte viendra qu'est-ce que vous
évoque le fait que on a plusieurs son
cloches sur le ban des ministres entre
géralde d'manin qui parle de lui du fait
qu'il est favorable à titre personnel
hier la ministre firmain le bonau qui
semblait un peu gêné sur le banc avec
cette avis de sagesse qu'est-ce que vous
en avez pensé la ministre firmain le
baudau a fait tout l'argumentaire contre
la suppression de la me pour dire
finalement sagesse c'est-à-dire que le
gouvernement laisse le Sénat se
prononcer avec une forme de
bienveillance pour son vote euh c'est de
la duplicité c'est de l'hypocrisie c'est
du cynisme je pense que c'est aussi un
peu de lâcheté et c'est pour cela que
notre président de groupe a interpellé
la première ministre sur la cacophonie
gouvernementale et sur la duplicité de
la position du gouvernement la première
ministre n'a pas vraiment répondu à sa
question elle a continué à gagner du
temps mais nous serons très vigilants
évidemment dans la suite de la
discussion parlementaire et bien merci
merci Rémy Ferraud pour cette réaction à
notre micro avant d'accueillir Yann
brossa ici sur ce plateau on va
retourner voir notre journaliste
parlementaire en tribune de presse
Mathias on parlait de cette
transformation de l'Ame en Amu qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé exactement en séance ben
écoutez c'est l'un des volets les plus
controversés du texte qui a été adopté
hier soir vous l'évoquez avec avec le
sénateur de Paris Rémi Ferro le Sénat a
supprimé l'aide médicale d'État qui
permet aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière de bénéficier d'un accès aux
soins une décision qu'a déploré la
première ministre ellisabeth B c'était
lors des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement la positionition est sans
ambigué c'est celle de mon gouvernement
qui a été exprimée très clairement hier
laame
laame laame est un dispositif laame est
un dispositif nécessaire qui répond à un
impératif de santé publique il doit
permettre de soigner les personnes
malades qui sont sur notre sol et par
ailleurs l'ame est aussi une protection
pour l'ensemble de nos citoyen car elle
permet de prévenir la propagation de
certaines maladies monsieur le Président
canner ma méthode est constante l'effet
le débat la recherche d'efficacité c'est
l'inverse même du dogmatisme et des
postures cette méthode c'est celle de
mon Gouvernement sur ce texte comme sur
les autres je vous remercie la première
ministre qui n'a pas enterré he cette
ame puisqu'elle a confié une mission ce
sera le rapport evvin stéphanini qui
doit revenir début décembre au
gouvernement pour établir l'intérêt de
cette de cette aide médicale d'État en
tout cas pour le la version du texte qui
a été voté ici au Sénat l'ame sera
remplacé par une aide médicale d'urgence
qui réduit considérablement le panier de
soins elle se limitera notamment aux
maladies graves aux douleurs aigues aux
soins liés à la grossesse ou encore au
vaccin Quentin merci Mathias SZ pour
toutes ces explications la séance qui va
reprendre maintenant d'ici 4 à 5 minutes
mais avant cela j'accueille ici sur ce
plateau Yann brossa bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur communiste de Paris
porte-parole du PCF un mot sur ce que
vient de dire Mathias et aussi sur ce
qui s'est joué en séance tout à l'heure
avec les explications de Madame bornne
on a vu la gauche un peu ironisé sur le
fait que le gouvernement avait une
position claire sur la transformation de
l'aide médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence que ça vous évoque vous on ne
comprend rien à la à la stratégie à la
position du Gouvernement sur le sujet
parce que vous avez d'un côté une
première ministre un ministre de la
Santé qui disent qu'ils sont attachés à
la l'accès aux soins et donc à l'aide
médicale d'État et dans le même temps
vous avez un gouvernement qui sur le
banc des ministres au Sénat s'en est
tenu un avis de sagesse c'est-à-dire
qu'ils n'ont pas véritablement défendu
l'aide médicale d'État donc il y a un
double langage et je regrette que l'aide
médicale d'État en face les frais et
qu'au final le Sénat se soit prononcé
contre le maintien de cette aide qui est
pourtant nécessaire on voit les les
praticiens notamment dans les hôpitaux
publics qui dénoncent ce vote d'hier je
vous lis ce communiqué de la Fédération
des hôpitaux publics qui dit que cette
réforme revient à affaiblir notre
système de santé à rebour du virage
préventif souhaité par tous les acteurs
en déplorant que les leçons de la
pandémie du covid-19 semblent oublié sur
le fond c'est grave ce qui s'est joué
sur la protection aussi même de tous les
Français oui c'est grave parce qu'il y a
plein de sujets dont on peut discuter
mais l'accès aux soins c'est une
question fondamentale et par ailleurs
tous les pays qui ont supprimé l'aide
médicale d'État je pense en particulier
à l'Espagne sont revenus de précisément
parce qu'au final ça coûte plus cher de
soigner les gens une fois que leurs
maladies se sont aggravé plutôt que
d'être dans une stratégie de prévention
et les soigner dès le départ y brossa on
entend la sonnerie qui raisonne dans le
palais du Luxembourg c'est que la séance
va reprendre d'un instant à l'autre on
va attaquer le chapitre 2 avec cette
fameuse mesure article 3 de séjour dans
les métiers en tenstion on a vu qu'il y
avait un accord depuis hier pour
supprimer cet article entre les alr et
les centriste et et aussi pour durcir la
circulaire Vals là qu'est-ce qui va se
jouer dans les prochaines minutes nelle
pour la gauche Séni c'est surtout une
défaite pour pour le pays et pour le
monde du travail parce que l'intérêt du
monde du travail c'est de sortir de
l'hypocrisie dans la dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec deux catégories
de travailleurs d'un côté des
travailleurs qui ont des papiers et qui
ont des droits et de l'autre des
travaillers des travailleurs qui n'ont
pas de papier et qui n'ont pas de droit
et c'est ce qui nourit le dumping social
et donc moi je reste convaincu comme la
majorité des Français d'ailleurs qu'il
faut la régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier et bien merci c'est le débat
qui sour à l'instant où l'on se parle
puisque la séence vient d'être reprise
c'est l'événement qu'on attend depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois ce
débat autour et bien des titres de
sesjour dans les métiers ention et c'est
Stéphane Ravier qui a la parole pour et
bien le mouvement reconquête onécoute
cette république la trème avait bien des
défauts mais elle n'a jamais failli sur
un point la nation vous connaissez le
modernestrenant une nation est une âme
un principe spirituel deux choses qui av
vrai dire en en en font qu'une constitue
cette âme ce principe spirituel l'une
est dans le passé l'autre dans le
présent l'une est la possession en
commun d'un riche l de souvenir l'autre
est le consentement actuel le désir de
vivre ensemble la volonté de continuer à
faire valoir l'héritage qu'on a reçu
l'intégration c'est le simple fait de
vivre ensemble l'assimilation c'est
devenir une partie de la nation
l'intégration c'est la vie en colocation
l'assimilation c'est l'appartenance à
une même famille dans une colocation la
vie commune et passagère transitoire et
déterminé dans le temps quand on est
dans une famille on est lié à jamais on
peut parfois le regretter on peut
parfois avoir envie de s'enfuir mais on
y vient on y parvient jamais vraiment
car le devoir moral supérieur de tout
individu et de prendre soin avant tout
autre considération de sa famille c'est
là qu'on y trouve sa qualité d'homme sa
vertu supérieur l'assimilation ce n'est
pas l'oubli de soi c'est la rencontre et
la fusion avec l'autre ce corps qui vous
accueille quand bien même vous lui futes
étranger à l'origine qui vous aime et
vous soutient pour peu que vous
remplissiez vos devoir à son égard être
français n'est pas n'est pas qu'un droit
c'est une somme de devoir à accomplir
pour en être digne en remplaçant le mot
intégration par assimilation vous
participerez mes chers collègues à faire
briller davantage ce si beau mot
français merci Monsieur R de la
commission merci madame le Président
d'abord permettez-moi de me réjouir
monsieur ravier que vos métaphores
soient désormais plus entendables par
cette cette émicité et que un étranger
qui demande un titre de séjour soit
assimilé à la Communauté française ça me
paraît vous en convrait tout à fait
excessif l'intégration paraît tout à
fait suffisante et c'est ce qui est
prévu d'ailleurs dans le CD nous allons
le conserver ainsi si vous le voulez
bien c'est un avis favorable défavorable
pardon de la commission très bien avis
du gouvernement
monsieur même avis donc je mets au voix
cet amendement avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour son adoption
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté amendement nous sommons nous
avons ensuite deux amendements
identiques le 123 présenté par Monsieur
Zurek merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre madame monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à exclure du champ des
discriminations l'application du
principe de priorité nationale notion
centrale de notre programme plébiscité
par 13 millions de Français à la
dernière élection présidentielle la
priorité nationale et la contrepartie
logique est naturel à la nationalité en
effet les Français doivent avoir un
droit prioritaire et pas exclusif chez
eux dans l'accès au logement social aux
aide sociale ou à l'emploi ainsi elle n
en rien une disposition de
discrimination ou d'exclusion mais un
droit logique et nécessaire appliqué
dans 95% des pays du monde cet
amendement vise donc à sortir du champ
des discriminations l'application du
principe de la priorité nationale qui é
également cher à Roger salangro merci à
vous merci amendement 529 présenté par
Monsieur ravier il est défend
non allez-y monsieur ravier ah oui oui
oui jusqu'au bout
euh adolp Landri vous ne connaissez sans
doute pas son nom et pourtant ce brave
ministre radical socialiste en décembre
1931 a soutenu une loi instaurant la
préférence nationale à l'emploi en
période de forte crise économique
heureusement que je suis là pour
remettre à l'honneur le radical
socialisme la priorité nationale la
préférence nationale appelez-la comme
vous voulez n'est pas une exception elle
est la règle dans la plupart des pays du
monde au premier rang desquel les
États-Unis ou le Brésil de Loula et
c'est bien normal après tout on
l'applique bien dans la fonction
publique il y a même une exclusivité
nationale dans la fonction publique on a
bien inventé l'exception culturelle
française pour protéger l'emploi des
français ce qui est possible pour Plus
belle la vie ne le serait pas pour les
caissières les manœuvres les agents
techniques ou les manutentionnaires
notre pays compte 5 millions de chômeurs
tout doit être mis en œuvre pour les
aider à retrouver un emploi j'ai bien
conscience que la la priorité nationale
ce n'est pas la recette miracle mais
elle aidera quelques centaines de
milliers de Français à retourner au
travail et quand bien quand bien même il
ntil qu'un seul ce résultat me
réjouirait retrouver un emploi c'est
retrouver la dignité la fierté le chemin
de la vie sociale la nation c'est
d'abord prendre soin des nôtres des
Français soumis trop souvent à une
concurrence déloyale étrangère qui coûte
moins cher qui réclame moins qui ne
s'organise pas car oui la préférence
nationale emploi c'est aussi permettre
aux salariés français de défendre leurs
droits la startup nation ce sont des
clandestins qui parcourent les rues des
métropoles à vélo ou à scooter pour
faire des livraisons sans contrat de
travail plutôt que d'employer des
Français qui connaissent le droit du
travail je préfère protéger le salarié
français que l'immigré sans papier ma
position ne souffre d'aucune ambiguïé
aucune hésitation il y a 30 ans déjà je
préférais mes filles à mes cousines mes
cousines à mes voisines et mes voisines
aux étrangères maintenant que j'ai que
que j'ai deux filles vous vous vous
comprendrez que je tiens à cette
priorité donc je vous invite mes chers
collègues à voter cet amendement de bon
sens merci Monsieur ravier avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
identiques merci madame le Président
vous nous invitez mes chers collègues à
sortir du champ des discrimination
l'application du principe de la priorité
nationale ça sorte quand même une
difficulté majeure qui est que le
principe de la pré de la priorité
nationale n'existe pas donc nous pouvons
difficilement y faire droit et et ce
d'autant plus que il existe tout de même
dans la loi des différences de droit
entre les nationaux les non nationaux ce
qui est tout à fait légal et ce qui me
paraît très largement suffisant l'avis
est défavorable défavorable avis du
gouvernement identique défavorable je
mets au voix ces deux amendements
identiques
avec monsieurur gr monsieur grevalet
pardonnez-moi
merci j'entends bien dans cette enceinte
que certains se revendiquent du radical
socialisme moi qui n' étaé que
socialiste toute ma vie radical le mot
est sans doute
faible
socialiste avec peut-être un autre
préfixe on aurait
pu le comprendre enfin sur cet
amendement puisqu'il est question
d'emploi puisqu'il est question de
chômage je voudrais dire que dans mon
département ou devant chaque entre re
reprise des panneaux surgistes pour
recruter 500 1000 salariés que nous
sommes en manque de main d'œuvre et et
et pour défendre les plus beaux fleurons
de l'industrie française je pense
évidemment à Airbus au construction
navale où nous avons cette fierté de
fabriquer des des objets magnifiques et
je ne parle pas évidemment de la
transition énergétique où nous avons
accueilli où nous fabriquons les plus
grandes éoliennes du monde heureusement
heureusement que dans ces entreprises il
y a des travailleurs étrangers 30 % dans
la construction navale sinon il y a bien
longtemps que la construction de ces
beaux éléments serait faite ailleurs
qu'en France donc je voulais le préciser
ici merci monsieur grovvalet je mets
maintenant au voix ces deux amendements
identiques qui ont reçu deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour leur
adoption voilà qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
nous avons ensuite un amendement 469
monsieur madame la Présidente cuckerman
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous nous
proposons à travers cet amendement
effectivement la remise au Parlement
d'un rapport sur l'application de la
circulaire d' Vals de 2012 qui donne un
cadre à la délivrance des admissions
exceptionnelles au séjour tout d'abord
nous le demandons parce que sans
dévoiler le suspense à venir l'article 3
tel
qu'initialement rédigé par vous monsieur
le ministre ou tel qu'il va l'être dans
quelques instants par la majorité ici au
Sénat vise effectivement à changer le le
logiciel si je peux le dire ainsi
puisque c'est ce que nous avions dénoncé
en son temps sur la circula la
circulaire Vals qui prévoyait pardon
effectivement la demande préalable de
l'employeur pour attester de la
régularisation du travailleur sans
papier également parce que les deux
rapports qui ont précédé ce projet de
loi ont mis en avant plusieurs limites
de cette circulaire au-delà de celle que
je viens d'évoquer tout d'abord elle
n'est pas utilisable devant les
tribunaux en cas de refus de séjour et
par ailleurs le Conseil d'État soulligne
que nombre de préfets ont décidé de
laisser sans réponse les demandes de
rendez-vous pour régularisation de
travailleurs enterrant de fait la
circulaire sur leur territoire face à la
pénurie de moyens humains les
renouvellements de titres de séjour sont
privilégiés dans nombre de préfectures
l'article donc 3 du projet de loi quel
il y en aura un à l'issue de nos débats
donc l'article 3 à venir prévoit dans
tous les cas la mise en place
expérimentale d'un nouveau titre de
séjour de plein droit et il nous semble
que cette expérimentation ne peut être
évaluée correctement sans la remise au
Parlement d'un rapport sur la mise en
œuvre et les limites de la circulaire
Vals pour répondre aux enjeux
socio-économiques de nos territoires tel
est le sens de l'amendement merci madame
la présidente Madame la rapporteur avis
de la Commission demande de rapport avis
défavorable avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement favorable défavorable
pardonnez-moi je mets au voix cet
amendement avec un double avis
défavorable qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté mes
chers collègues nous
arrivons à l'article 3 tant attendu et
je vais donner la parole au président
buffet rappel au règlement monsieur
président canner après le
présidentment çae monsieur le Président
bien merci Madame la président quelques
observations au moment où nous abordons
le fameuse article
3 chacun a bien compris
que il y avait des divergences de vue
sur cet article en particulier sur sa
portée on peut l'appeler desésaccords
c'est pas une question de point clair
là-dessus en particulier sur sa portée
l'article 3 d'origine du texte nous n'y
ét pas favorable en tous les cas pour ce
qui concerne le groupe les
républicains considérant que il pouvait
engendrer une régularisation
importante pour ne pas dire
et que nous n'étions pas sur cette ligne
là pour faire très clair nos collègues
d'autres collègues étaient plutôt nos
collègues centristes d'ailleurs étaient
plutôt sur une une autre approche ce qui
fait que nous avions décidé en
commission des lois de venir en séance
pour mener le débat les choses ont
évolué chacun le sait maintenant puisque
nous les rapporteurs déposeront ont
déposer un amendement additionnel après
l'article 4 cet amendement additionnel
après l'article 4 renvoie au pouvoir
réglementaire je reste dans les grandes
lignes la possibilité de régulariser des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
présent sur le territoire avec ayant un
contrat de travail et souhaitant rentrer
dans la procédure d'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour il y a
évidemment un certain nombre de
conditions supplémentaires dans cet
amendement je le présente mais les
rapporteurs le diront les conditions de
présence sur le territoire des
conditions de durée des conditions liées
au respect des valeurs de la République
au sens large du terme et la possibilité
et la demande qui est faite au préfet
dans le cadre de la procédure
d'admission exceptionnelle au séjour de
saisir l'employeur qui est le cignataire
évidemment du contrat de travail afin
que soit vérifié la réalité de ce
travail la conséquence de cet amendement
qui est déposé c'est évidemment la
suppression de l'article 3 d'origine
dans le texte la procédure va donc nous
amener à à cela mais je veux dire que
c'est un ensemble qui est bien clair
nous avons souhaité cette suppression et
nous voterons la suppression de
l'article 3 qui été présenté par le
gouvernement et qui est en discussion
maintenant et nous proposerons un
amendement qui est l'amendement
additionnel après l'article 4 qui remet
en place le met en place plutôt le
dispositif que je viens d'évoquer
j'indique également à la Haute Assemblée
même si nous ne sommes pas encore à
l'article 4 queégalement l'article 4
sera également supprimé les choses sont
parfaitement très clair voilà comment
les choses se présentent maintenant je
regarde le temps qu'il me reste euh
évidemment le débat va peut-être vous
apparaître un peu compliqué parce que
nous avons des amendements des
amendements additionnels pardon des
articles additionnels qui seront en
discussion mais qui seront supprimés
bien sûr mais la discussion aura lieu
c'est la règle il n'empêche que sur le
fond c'est l'amendement euh 657 qui
viendra remplacer purement et simplement
la suppression de l'article
3 merci monsieurons bien qu'il soit voté
mais merci monsieur le Président avant
de donner la parole au ministre je vais
donner la parole au président canner
pour un rappel au règlement oui madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
madame la ministre euh nous souhaitons
faire un rappel au Règlement sur la base
de l'article 33 alinéa
2 qui vous autorise madame la Présidente
à suspendre la séance à la demande donc
d'un membre du de la Haute Assemblée
c'est ce que nous vous demandons pour
une raison simple et j'espère que
Monsieur Darmanin ne voudra pas me taxé
cette fois-ci d'indélicatesse sur le
fait que je souhaite que sur ces débats
qui nous attendent nous souhaitons nous
puissions avoir le ministre au ban ah
bah
oui et je n'oublie pas qu'il y a
quelques mois je recevais dans mon
bureau et j'ai les témoins monsieur du
sopt et Monsieur Darmanin pour nous
présenter le grand équilibre j'ai pas
dit le grand écart le grand équilibre de
cette de ce projet de loi entre la
partie intégratrice et la partie gestion
des flux migratoire donc je vous direz
nous avons la chance d'avoir le ministre
de l'Intérieur donc éventuellement il
pourrait lancer un avis de recherche
pour ministre
disparu ce serait intéressant mais là
Monsieur dus sopt n'est pas devant une
autre instance juridictionnelle si vous
voyez à quoi je peux faire allusion
monsieur darin donc il peut venir au
banc et donc madame la Présidente je
sollicite
un une suspension de séance d'un temps
nécessaire un qu d'heure ou 20 minutes
pour que le ministre Olivier duop puisse
venir au ban défendre l'article 3 et
l'article 4 dont il est l'initiateur au
nom du gouvernement très bien monsieur
le Président canner cette décision
relevant effectivement de la présidence
je ne donnerai pas suite cont tenu des
nombreuses prises de parole qu'il y a
avant le commencement de l'examen dans
le fond de cet article monsieur le
ministre
merci Madame Présidente je regrette que
je ne vous suffise pas
monsieur monsieur monsieur monsieur
monsieur le Président d'autant plus que
très largement et médiatiquement vous
avez pris l'occasion de dire la loi
d'armanin ou Géral d'armanin donc se
coup vous cherchez vous-même l'équilibre
mais c'est évidemment une démarche qui
ne trompe personne pour éviter de de
parler sans doute de de ce sujet moi je
remercie la présentation du président de
de la commission des lois et
l'acceptation par la séance d'une
discussion commune finalement entre le 3
et puis le 4 bis si j'ai bien compris
qui est l'amendement que a fait naître
madame la
rapporteur tout à l'heure et qui
discutera sur le remplacement du 3 en 4
bits enfin qu'importe le numéro quelle a
été la volonté du gouvernement et
finalement quel est ce qu'on nous
propose la volonté du gouvernement a été
de régler un double problème
qu'aujourd'hui le règlement ne peut pas
régler vous ne pouvez pas régulariser
une personne qui est dans l'irrégularité
et qui travaille et qui parfois
travaille dans des conditions
extrêmement diverses on l'a vu dans les
premiers article de ce texte de loi on
n'y reviendra pas les statuts sont très
divers si son employeur ne veut pas le
régulariser donc les régularisations qui
se font aujourd'hui notamment au nom de
la circulaire bals je rappelle qu'elles
se font d'ailleurs essentiellement sur
le volet famille 23000 personnes plutôt
que sur volet de travail 7000 personnes
par an vous ne pouvez pas régulariser
personne dit le code du travail si
l'employeur ne permet pas la
régularisation s'il ne signe pas le
SERFA qui permet la régularisation voilà
pourquoi des gens sont parfois devant
les préfectures parfois soutenu par des
élus parfois soutenu par des syndicats
par des associations pour être
régularisé il n'y a pas de
régularisation malgré une volonté
politique ou préfectorale parce que la
loi est au-dessus évidemment de la
volonté préfectorale ou ministérielle
donc la première volonté du gouvernement
était de mettre fin à à ce ce ce servage
d'un temps moderne que
l'employeur pouvait s'opposer à la
régularisation de son employé qui
pourtant demandait la régularisation et
pourquoi il s'y opposé il s'y opposait
pas pour des raisons évidemment de
respect absolu du de la lutte contre
l'irrégularité puisque sinon il aurait
pas embauché son son employé sinon il
l'aurait s'en serait séparé rapidement
bien sûr
il le fait parce qu'il ne veut pas qu'on
découvre sans doute qu'il emploie
lui-même des personnes irrégulières et
qu' en a pas qu'une et qu'il faut faire
le contrôle et que l'inspection du
travail et d'autres font ce travail de
contrôle et effectivement c'est très
cohérent avec l'un article qui va arrivé
que malheureusement la commission des
lois a supprimé on en reparlera plus
tard ce soir ou demain qui est la
sanction administrative extrêmement
forte contre l'entreprise qui embauche
des irréguliers de façon évidente et
sans avoir été trop par ses salariés
donc notre dispositif gouvernemental est
en premier lieu c'est ça en premier lieu
l'article 3 la possibilité législative
de faire sauter si je dire ce verrou du
Code du travail régulariser quelqu'un
sans son
employeur deuxièmement il
avait comme objectif et il a toujours
comme objectif le fait de régulariser
des personnes dans certaines conditions
qui souvent sont dans ce qu'on appelle
les Ninis ni ni
régularisable pas expulsable parce que
évidemment leur vie privée familiale est
désormais en France ça fait de très
longues années qu' sont venus en France
la grande moitié des personnes que nous
avons à constater sont là depuis plus de
10 ans du territoire national ça date
pas du ququen d'Emmanuel Macron ni du
second ni du premier mais pas
régularisable parce queils sont dans les
régularités et que aucun texte de loi ne
permet de le faire parfois un peu la
circulaire Vals mais pas totalement
notamment sur les questions que j'ai
évoqué et et comme ils sont souvent
employés dans des métiers dit en tension
où là le chômage qui n'est pas le refuge
en se disant il y a des réguliers qui
sont au chômage où il y a des Français
qui sont au chômage formonsles pour les
mettre évidemment c'est une bonne
réflexion que partage le gouvernement
dans les métiers d'irentention dans
certaines zones géographiques dit
l'article 3 c'est métier en tenstion et
zone géographique tendu donc ce n'est
pas partout sur le territoire national
c'est pas dans un endroit où il y a
beaucoup de chômage répondons à certains
critères depuis plus de 3 ans sur le
territoire national
nous pouvions imaginer le régularisation
avec en effet une prescription le préfet
doit alors régulariser un titre de
séjour d'un an d'un an qui n'ouvre pas
droit au mouement familial c'est exprimé
expressis verbis et par ailleurs une
clause de cette loi s'arrêté en 2026 ce
qui évitait tout appel d' même si j'ai
eu du mal évidemment dans le débat
médiatique à le démontrer parce que la
caricature était plus facile puisque
c'était évidemment une clause de 3 ans
sur le territoire national qui s'arrêta
en 26 puisque nous étions à la fin de la
années 23 il était évident que ces
personnes n'étaient pas concernées
personne pouvait venir en France en
imaginant trouver cette
régularisation ceci dit l'important
comme je me suis déjà exprimé c'est
l'esprit de compromis que veut le
gouvernement pour avoir l'essentiel de
ce qu'il demande une mesure de
régularisation de personnes qui
travaillent dans notre pays sur notre
pays depuis très longtemps et dont les
patrons ne veulent pas les régulariser
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas signer SF
pour pas qu'on découvre le poteorose
nous avons euh entendu le compromis qui
a trouvé la majorité sénatoriale que
nous appelions de nos vœux nous l'avons
eu un amendement hier soir il est celui
qui va faire naître le 4 bis il est
évidemment bien sûr acceptable pour le
gouvernement il y a un certain nombre de
dispositions qu'il faudra sans doute il
y a sans doute des dispositions qu'il
faudra modifier soit parce qu'elles ont
été me semble-t-il écrites un peu à la
hâte soit parce que parfois elles sont
plus larges que les volonté
gouvernementale je fai remarquer avec un
plaisir non non fin à Monsieur rillot
que il il il régularise plus de monde
que nous l'aurions fait puisque il il il
évite que certaines périodes de séjour
régulier des durées prises en compte
pour apprécier la satisfaction de
condition de séjour ne soit pas concerné
par exemple nous on avait dit que la
qualité de demandeur d'asile ne rentrait
pas ou que le titre de séjour étudiant
ou travailleurs saisoners ne rentrait
pas mais ceci étant dit je suis sûr que
vous vter sous amendement du
Gouvernement qui complétera l'amendement
l'amendement qu' Biss tout ça pour dire
que le gouvernement tout ça pour dire si
si monsieur le président de la
commission des lois je vous l'assure
mais on en parle lea tout ça pour dire
que le gouvernement donnera un avis un
avis de sagesse euh sur
l'amendement sur l'amendement du 4 du 4
bis parce qu'évidemment il faudra que
nous le retravaillons sans doute à
l'Assemblée nationale continuera à dire
qu'évidemment il tient à son article 3
et donc un avis évidemment qui
permettrait de garder l'article 3 tout
en comprenant qu'il y a un compromis
politique à obtenir ici au Sénat et donc
demain évidemment à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est l'engagement que je
prends avec les parlementaires mais sont
évidemment libres de modifier les choses
je vrais II dire évidemment que c'est la
position entière monsieur canner du
gouvernement d'Olivier dusop qui
s'exprimait publiquement cet après-midi
mais je peux peut-être vous envoyer la
capture vidéo de son intervention si
vous n'avez pas eu le loisir d'avoir des
moyens de communication modernes dont
pourtant notre département du Nord Est
est pourvu et vous dire qu'évidemment je
je remercie de cet état d'esprit
remercier tous les groupes qui ont
participé et singulièrement le président
Marseille qui a porté des modifications
qui auraient pu être également
intéressantes et qui sont repris je
crois dans l'amendement proposé voilà
cet article 3 comme cet article 4 bis
n'est pas l'essentiel du texte de loi il
est un article sur 48 il concerne en
moyenne dans la version gouvernementale
7000 personnes par an et il était un
article qui se terminait de lui-même en
2026 je crois qu'il ne méritait pas ni
les bravos ni les aénissements de ceux
qui considéraient que c'était affreux ou
de ceux qui
considéraent de ceux qui considéraent de
ceux qui considéraent que c'était
l'alpha et l'oméga du texte c'est
évidemment une mesure qui avant tout
permet de régler des problèmes
individuels qui sont aujourd'hui
insolubl surtout féminins les problèmes
qui sont concernés ici c'est surtout des
femmes qui son concerné par cet article
3 et 4 bis et surtout il nous permet de
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
de ceux qui embauchent des personnes de
façon irrégulière et j'espère que nous
mettrons ainsi fin un écosystème irrégué
avec deux dispositions du texte donc
voilà madame la Présidente parce que
j'imagine qu'il aura beaucoup de pris de
parole la la la clarté que voudrait
avoncer le gouvernement sur les
propositions faites par le Sénat très
bien merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est désormais à Monsieur à Madame
Audrey
linkeld merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le
ministre il n'est pas simple de
s'exprimer sur cet article 3 quand je me
suis inscrite c'était probablement pas
tout à fait le même article 3 c'était en
tout cas celui que vient au départ de
son propos de présenter monsieur le
ministre depuis nous avons connu le
moment où l'article 3 et l'article 4 ont
été réservés puis le moment où ils ont
été déréservés puis le moment où ils
sont amendés pour se transformer en un
article 4 bis donc plutôt que de
d'essayer de commenter finalement un
article dont on ne sait plus très bien
le quel il est et ce qui le contient
précisément je vais euh plutôt dire ce
qui nous euh sur les bancs des du groupe
socialiste nous paraissait intéressant
dans cet article puisqu'il fait partie
des des rares sujets sur lesquels on
pouvait considérer qu'il y avait des
avancées positives dans ce projet de loi
immigration et et intégration ce ce
qu'il nous semble à nous c'est que en
effet euh des travailleurs euh sans
papiers mais en France depuis au moins 3
ans travaillant depuis plusieurs mois
déjà exerçant des métiers dont nous
avons tous besoin dans notre société
auxiliaire de vie gardien agent de de
nettoyage cuisinier plongeur voilà que
ces travailleursl pouvaient avoir droit
à une carte de séjour temporaire sans
avoir à en passer par l'analyse
individuelle d'un préfet mais de plein
droit parce que la loi reconnaît la
contribution qui est à l'heure à notre
économie et à notre société voilà ce que
nous défendons voilà ce que nous allons
continuer à défendre y compris avec des
amendements qui permettront peut-être
d'aller encore plus loin que ce que
prévoyait l'article 3 et ce que prévoira
l'article 4 bis merci Madame madame
ponémonge merci madame la Présidente
alors depuis des semaines des
travailleurs sans papiers sont en grève
dans une trentaine de sites
d'île-de-fance dont ceux des JO ils
manifeste devant les agences d'intérim
les entreprises de nettoyage il demande
à ce que la raison et la justice
voudrait que que nous demandions à
savoir la régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papierers l'article 3
qui reçoit tant de critiques sur les
bans de la droite réduit pourtant
toujours ces travailleurs dont une
grande partie ça a été dit sont employés
sur des métiers difficiles et dangereux
à une partie une immigration toujours
choisie comme entériné après les grandes
grèves des sanspiers de 2008 par Nicolas
Sarkozy et Don la liste des 30 métiers a
ensuite été formalisé par la circulaire
Vals brise sortefeu dis disait la loi
que j'ai fait voter prévoit de
régulariser au cas par cas dans des
secteurs connaissant de graves pénuries
de main d'œuvre donc rien de nouveau
mais c'est encore trop il faut durcir
durcir et surtout laisser les
régularisations à la main des employeurs
même à postériori cette politique
d'immigration jetable est à l'œuvre et
est à l'œuvre depuis 15 ans et la droite
trouve encore trop laxiste l'article 3
qui voulait effectivement l'adoucir
c'est une politique inadapté en plus de
son coup humain comme le constate
Emeline zoubéé sociologue au CNRS la
liste des métiers entention tel qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui ne correspond pas du
tout au postees qu'occupent les sans
papiers problème que faites-vous des
travailleurs sans papier qui ne sont pas
donc dans les soi-disants métiers en
tenstion et que ferez-vous de ceux qui
ne le SER qui le seront puis qui ne le
seront plus de ceux qui travaillent
depuis des années et font tenir les
entreprises et des secteurs entiers et
par participe ainsi à l'effort collectif
ce que nous devrions défendre ce que les
écologistes défendent la position
raisonnable et humaniste c'est la
régularisation de tous les travailleurs
sans papierers de plein droit avec un
titre de séjour durable nous en sommes
loin et même limité aux emplois vacants
la droite trouve que c'est encore trop
par pure idéologie merci madame pensong
monsieur le Président canner merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la
ministre j'ai dans les mains le projet
de loi initial contrôler l'immigration
améliorer l'intégration et j'ai pris
l'exposé des motifs que vous avez donc
validé avec Monsieur lopt monsieur le
ministre
euh concernant l'article 3 la carte de
séjour temporaire mention travail dans
des métiers en tension relèverait de la
seule initiative du travailleur étranger
elle serait délivrée de plein droit sous
réserve de la preuve apportée par tout
moyen d'une ancienneté de résidence sur
le territoire et cetera et cetera
c'était l'esprit de l'article 3 qui
manifestement est aujourd'hui dénaturé
et bien je tiens à vous dire que nous
nous opposerons à la dénaturation de
l'article 3 et aussi de l'article 4 au
passage dénaturation qui est résumé dans
le l'amendement créant un article 4 bis
dans ce projet de loi euh chers
collègues régulariser une personne qui
vit en France qui travaille bah c'est
tout simplement reconnaître sa
participation à la vie de notre société
et Monsieur Darmanin a évoqué notre
point commun il y en a quand même à
savoir d'être du Nord combien de patrons
que j'ai pu rencontrer dans ma campagne
électorale comme d'autres ici pendant 5
semaines 6 semaines au mois d'août et de
septembre me disait mais donnez-nous
finalement l'encadrement juridique qui
nous permett de donner une vie correcte
à celles et ceux qui enrichissent notre
notre pays je ne suis pas dans le Patos
je suis dans la réalité économique et
même sur les bandes droitees ici vous
savez qu'il y a cette demande qui qui
est existe alors c'est vrai que nous
nous voulons une société un vivre
ensemble dans une république inclusive
et tout ce qui ira contre les principes
finalement généreux du projet de loi
initial et bien nous nous y opposerons
avec force avec vigueur nous voulons des
personnes autonomes intégrées dans notre
République et même si elles sont
étrangères elles méritent notre
consération et encore une fois notre
bienveillance voilà l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous porterons nos amendements à
vos différentes propositions merci
monsieur le Président Madame
Floren merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames madame et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous l'avons affirmé dès la
discussion générale nous n'avons jamais
été des fétichistes de l'article 3 notre
démarche est pragmatique guidée par la
volonté de parvenir à un compromis
satisfaisant savoir si le dispositif est
à l'article 3 après l'article 3 le 4 ou
le 13 nous importe peu encore une fois
nous ne comprenons pas du tout
l'effervescence suscité par cette
disposition sur les métiers en tension
fallait-il créer un nouveau titre de
séjour avec des critères ouvrant un
droit à régularisation dans les métiers
en tension non et ce n'est pas nouveau
c'est ce que nous répétons depuis des
mois notre ligne sur le sujet est
parfaitement claire et n'a pas bougé le
plus efficace nous l'avions déjà dit est
de ver comme aujourd'hui le pouvoir
d'appréciation des préfets dans une
gestion des dossiers au cas par cas y
compris dans les métiers en tension
c'est ce que prévoit l'amendement que
nous avions déposé à l'article 3 que
nous avons déposé à l'article 3
l'article 3 en tant que tel pose un
problème un problème symbolique pas de
problème mettons cette disposition
ailleurs dans le texte s'appuyons
clairement sur le dispositif de notre
amendement la commission nous propose
aujourd'hui UNEP i en additionnel à
l'article 4 et bien mes chers collègues
sans surprise cela nous convient
parfaitement nous sommes attachés au
fond de cet article pas à la forme comme
nous le souhaitons le dispositif proposé
prévoit bien de modifier le régime
applicable en matière d'autorisation de
travail cela a été rappelé un salarié
sans papier qui souhaite régulariser sa
situation doit recueillir l'accord de
son employeur à travers la signature
d'un formulaire f et de pouvoir afin de
pouvoir proposer sa son demander son
titre de séjour nous souhaitons pas que
cette disposition soit maintenue c'est
la raison pour laquelle il faut prévoir
sa suppression la suppression de
l'accord préalable donc dans la solution
retenutr excusez-moi madame la
Présidente par la
commission aura ni d'appel d'air ni de
dénis de réalité mercici madame Floren
monsieur
Bross merci Madame la président monsieur
le
ministre je voudrais exprimer ici les
les les regrets de notre groupe nous
n'avons jamais considéré que l'article 3
était était une panacée nous avions
plein de propositions à faire pour pour
en améliorer la rédaction pour en pour
en étendre
l'application mais tout le monde a bien
compris le sort qui sera réservé à cet
article 3 par la majorité sénatoriale je
dis des regrets parce que cet article 3
permettait au
moins de commencer à sortir d'une forme
d'hypocrisie qui fait que des milliers
de personnes qui travaillent en France
qui se lèv tôt qui se couche tard qui
bosse dans des métiers
pénibles le font aujourd'hui sans papier
et donc sans droit des personnes qui
bossent dans le ménage qui travaillent
comme
hboueur qui travaill dans les travaux
publics et qui bien souvent payent des
impôts
et paye des cotisations sociales et de
fait la circulaire Vals avait des
éléments qui à nos yeux étaient quand
même un peu absurde que pour régulariser
un travailleur sans papier on a besoin
de l'autorisation de l'employeur
c'est-à-dire de celui qui bien souvent
siamment a fait le choix d'embaucher un
travailleur sans papier on se retrouve
avec un travailleur sans papier qui doit
qu'ander auprès de son employur une
autorisation remplir un SERFA qui lui
permette d'être régularisé tout cela
avait quelque chose d'absurde cet
article 3 nous permettait d'avancer et
je regrette que la majorité sénatoriale
a fait le choix de sacrifier cet élément
et de sortir de cette manière-là de de
l'hypocrisie un regret donc mais une
satisfaction malgré tout c'est que
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion le
prouvent la majorité des Français qui
pourtant sont dur sur les questions
d'immigration sont favorables à la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier et je pense que cela témoigne que
cela vous déplaise c'est une chose mais
c'est la réalité et à un moment donné il
faut être capable de regarder la réalité
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick
Jadeau merci merci Madame merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues on arrive à un point clé de ce
débat c'est
évident monsieur le ministre quand vous
avez présenté ce projet de loi avec une
formule un peu infantilis mais on va la
reprendre ce projet de là ce projet de
loi c'est pour être méchant avec les
méchants et gentil avec les gentils le
résultat c'est que ce projet de loi
c'est simplement être méchant avec les
gentils quand on regarde vous n'avez pas
arrêé ce ce projet de loi et ce débat
n'est construit que sur des mensonges et
des
contrevérités le mot clé le mot clé que
vous avez incontestablement réussi à
faire passer dans l'opinion publique
c'est appel d' pas une étude pas un
expert pas un chef d'entreprise pas un
syndicaliste ne confirme l'appel d'
l'immigration serait incontrôlable c'est
faux aucune statistique ne le valide il
faudrait revenir sur la dignité des
personnes attaquer les étudiants refuser
de soigner les immigrés il faudrait
limiter les mariages mix et le regroup
familial et c'est comme ça qu'on
répondrait à un enjeu de
société vous êtes à côté ce débat est un
débat parallèle est un un monde
parallèle par rapport à la réalité les
Françaises et les Français les
entreprises les citoyens attend du Sénat
ils attendent que nous répondions sur le
fond à la question de l'immigration et
aujourd'hui c'est un projet de loi du
désordre et du mensonge parce que
laisser des dizaines de milliers de
personnes dans l'illégalité dans
l'indignité dans la précarité alors
qu'ils construisent la France
avec merci la parole est à Monsieur
[Musique]
benaroche la parole est à Monsieur
benaroche monsieur
benaroche
ch
sil monsieur benaroch et à lui seul
merci beaucoup je vous remercie madame
la
Présidente je voulais faire une petite
jeunèe de cette histoire de ce projet de
loi en fait monsieur le
ministre je vous rappelle quand même le
titre premier s'appelle assurer une
meilleure intégration des étrangers par
le travail nous sommes rencontrés
d'ailleurs au tout début début comme
vous avez rencontré tous les présidents
de groupe du Sénat accompagné d'un
certain nombre de sénateurs j'étais donc
avec le président Guillaume gottard
lorsque vous nous avez reçu avec Olivier
du sopt qui à ce moment-là était souvent
présent on l'attend peut-être je ne sais
pas et vous nous avez expliqué qu'elle
était quelles étaient vos intentions
monsieur le ministre et nous vous avons
dit avec Guillaume Gard que nous les
comprenions nous pouvions même envisager
que nous pourrions apporter un certain
nombre d'idées supplémentaires à cell
que vous vous aviez déjà évoqué qui on
été rappelé tout à l'heure pour une
meilleure intégration par le travail en
France des
immigrés après cette après ce début
monsieur Darmanin cette loi est arrivée
au Sénat elle a été profondément
modifiée par la commission des Lois du
Sénat puis elle a été stoppée net dans
son élant par le gouvernement euh on a
entendu qu' en aurait finalement deux et
puis après on a dit qu'il en aurait zéro
et puis peut-être qu' en aurait une une
et puis peut-être qu' il y en aurait une
à un moment donné on ne sait pas quand
et nous sommes retrouvés devant le
retour au projet de loi voté par le
Sénat à la version
sénatoriale maintenant et la principale
différence c'est que maintenant la
négociation qui avait lieu avant a eu
lieu en direct live au Sénat et que donc
en fait vous l'avez dit vous-même d'un
projet qui était fait pour favoriser
l'intégration par le travail en France
il il en est ressorti un projet qui a
pour seul intérêt pour vous d'arriver à
un consensus parce que ce qui compte
pour vous c'est l'esprit de compromis
c'estàdire le consensus politicien voilà
ce qui est devenu le projet de loi
travail et intégration par le travail
monsieur le ministre et monsieur le
sénateur monsieur benaroche la parole
est maintenant à Madame
Vogel merci madame la Présidente alors
en effet on arrive au moment de la
discussion de l'article qui au fond
était là pour servir les éléments de
langage du gouvernement nous avons un
projet équilibré il marche sur deux
jambes la jambe des horreurs et la
chambre des douceurs alors les horreurs
on a vu hein depuis lundi suppression de
la me durcissement du regroupement
familial décalage des allocations
familiales et cetera et cetera et puis
là on devait arriver à la jambe des
douceurs très faible hein il s'agissait
de donner un peu de dignité à un peu de
personnes pendant un peu de temps
c'était ça l'article 3 et là il est
question de l'amputer cette jambe alors
de la part des républicains et de la
majorité sénatoriale ça surprendra
personne la véritable information de ce
soir c'est celle qui vient du
gouvernement en réalité quand vous nous
dites que vous êtes prêt à donner un
avis de sagesse sur la suppression de
l'article 3 qui était l'article que vous
vendiez partout dans la presse pour
expliquer vous avez donné un avis de
sagesse sur l'amendement 655 est un
amendement de suppression de l'article 3
monsieur le ministre ou alors j'ai mal
compris j'espère vous le corrigerez la
véritable information de ce soir c'est
que le gouvernement préfère perdre
l'honneur pour garder une loi que de
perdre un
vote pour garder la
face merci Madame Vogel le président
retaillo bien oui merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre bien sûr
que c'est un moment clé de la discussion
de ce texte et depuis le départ nous
avons dit notre opposition à l'article 3
et à l'article 4 et ce soir j'espère
bien qu'ils seront
supprimés alors c'est extraordinaire
monsieur le ministre vous manquez pas
d'air je sais qu'en politique le culot
c'est souvent une qualité je le
reconnais et vous voulez faire croire
que le dispositif proposé par la
majorité sénatoriale c'est l'équivalent
finalement de du dispositif que vous
proposie mais queeneni ou alors les
groupes de gauche se trompent pourquoi
est-ce que tous les groupes de gauche
montent au créneau parce que eux voit
bien la comparaison et ils savent bien
que la proposition qu'on fait c'est pas
du tout la proposition initiale qui
était le sommet le paroxisme de la
macronie en même temps pourquoi on
s'opposait et pourquoi c'est beaucoup
plus restrictif parce que vous l'article
3 notamment c'est un droit automatique
vous fraudez et plus longtemps vous
fraudez plus la fraude est dissimulée et
plus ça vous génère et plus la fraude
est créatrice de droit d'un droit
opposable d'un droit automatique que
même l'administration ne pourra pas
stopper ben nous on voulait pas et c'est
pour ça qu'on va le supprimer et qu'on
le remplace par un durcissement de la
circulaire et votre dispositif n'est pas
quantifiable mais c'était des dizaines
de milliers sans doute de régularisation
le nôtre est beaucoup beaucoup plus
quantifiable et surtout il est tenable
il est tenable parce qu'il ne crée pas
un droit aut
et nous allons durcir ce qu'on appelle
la circulaire V mais ça sera pour les
médeins enention et si d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre si d'ailleurs il y
avait un sous-amendement pour le
restreindre encore plus moi j'invite les
collègues de gauche et de droite à le
voter même si ça vient de vous
voyez merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
Dosu merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais dire que je suis d'accord avec
le ministre quand il a justifié la
désertion ou la capitulation du du
gouvernement en race campagne
d'aujourd'hui pas quand il a dit cet
article 3 ne méritait pas grand-chose
c'est la réalité nous aussi nous pension
qu'il méritait pas grand-chose puisque
nous les écologistes nous sommes
attachés à la valeur du travail à
l'égalité des droits et donc à la
régularisation des travailleurs ceux qui
travaillent ici ceux qui parfois payent
des cotisations ici ont droit au même
droit que les autres travailleurs ici la
droite préfère les clandestins et le
travaille noir comme ça vient d'être dit
par le président retaillot
et donc pourtant le Président reetaillot
il y a quelques jours encore nous disait
on veut plus d'article 3 du tout on ne
veut même plus de jeu de bon tau avec
une réécriture de l'article 3 ailleurs
dans le texte qu'est-ce que nous allons
faire aujourd'hui un jeu de bonne tau on
va supprimer cet article 3 on va le
réécrire en pire certes mais on va quand
même le réécrire en dessous et donc il
n'y a pas que le certainement
pas certain et donc on régissre on
réécrit un dispositif pire pour les
travailleurs pire que le dispositif
existant c'est déjà un à la parole
monsieur benénaroche laissez-le parler
et donc ça a été dit le texte qui va
sortir à la fin de ce Sénat c'est le
cabinet des horreur c'est en réalité
l'accord scellé non pas entre le LR les
centristes et le gouvernement c'est
l'accord scellé entre LR et le
rassemblement national puisque tout ce
qu'on trouve là dans ce texte c'est le
programme du rassemblement national voir
le programme du Front national
historique des années 90 c'est le pire
de PE ce qu'on peut trouver et les dig
on sauté les centristes se sont fait
engloutir dans dans cette calamité au
revoir merci Monsieur DSU madame de La
[Applaudissements]
Gonterie merci madame la
Présidente chers collègue monsieur le
ministre j'ai fait partie d'une d'un
rassemblement de par parlementaire de
toute tendance politique y compris des
membres du parti Renaissance qui ont
estimé effectivement euh nécessaire de
venir au soutien de ce qui était
l'article 3 pourquoi tout simplement
pour mettre un terme à ce qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure le mot a été
utilisé
l'hypocrisie nous savons tous vous savez
tous que nous avons parmi nos proches ou
dans nos villes des personnes qui
travaillent dans des restaurants qui
travaillent dans des supermarchés qui
travaillent parfois dans le BTP et qui
sont en situation irrégulière donc à
partir de là deux solutions soit vous
faites en sorte que ces personnes
quittent le
territoire soit vous considérez ce qui
est le cas des syndicats d'employeurs du
syndicat de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration qu'il y a besoin de ces
personnes pour faire tourner
l'économie donc y a-t-il un intérêt
alors que nous en avons besoin à
maintenir ces personnes dans
l'illégalité donc dans la précarité on a
beaucoup parlé de la circ Vals elle
avait un défaut majeur c'est
l'autorisation de l'employeur j'indique
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure que
l'amendement qui est proposé par les
rapporteurs réintreduit l'intervention
de l'employeur et que donc nous aurons à
y revenir mais elle avait un deuxième
défaut c'est que
elle laissait effectivement le libre
arbitre du préfet est-ce que vous savez
sans doute monsieur le ministre mais il
faudrait le reconnaître ou plutôt y
faire face c'est que les préfectures
avaient un comportement totalement
hétérogène et que donc on ne pouvait pas
considérer et c'est sans doute pour cela
que votre texte utilisait le fait que
cette carte était octroyée de droit et
elle avait un plus cette circulaire Vals
que n'a pas l'amendement qui est proposé
c'est qu'elle s'appliquait dans tous les
secteurs professionnels alors
aujourd'hui nous ne parlons que des
métiers en ttention donc il faudra bien
y revenir tout à l'heure merci donc
voilà pourquoi nous soutenions et voilà
pourquoi nous allons combattre ce qui
est proposé de manière trop restrictive
aujourd'hui merci madame de la gonri
madame la Présidente cuckerman oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crois
qu'effectivement et en toute
sincérité l'article tel qu'écrit
initialement et celui qui va nous être
proposé n'est pas tout à fait le même
d'ailleurs s'ilétait nous n serions pas
là et donc je je je crois que cela a
fait déjà couler beaucoup d'ancre fait
parler beaucoup de personnes en revanche
ce qui nous satisfaisait et je l'ai déjà
évoqué dans cette cette vision de
l'article 3 initiale était effectivement
qu'elle
mettait un stop à une des vraie
difficulté de la circulaire Vals comme
ça a déjà été dit qui per qui rend
finalement les employeurs qui
employaient eux-mêmes des travailleurs
sans papiers comme ceux qui donnaient
autorisation ou non à leur
régularisation et l'on comprend là quand
même toute la difficulté y compris même
philosophique à accepter une telle
démarche je crois que nous avons
finalement un petit débat de méthode
parce que
j'entends la la crainte si je peux le
dire ainsi de de de certains nombreux
d'ailleurs ce soir euh d'une d'une porte
ouverte d'un appel d'air qui ferait
venir des dizaines des centaines des
milliers je laisse chacun apprécier
l'échelle de de travilleur sans papier
mais je crois qu'on on se trompe de
débat ces femmes et ces hommes
aujourd'hui sont présents ils sont
présents sur notre territoire notre
collègue précédemment de l' Atlantique
le rappelait ils sont aujourd'hui celles
et ceux qui travaillent dans nos
industries celles et ceux qui
travaillent dans des dans les
entreprises agricoles celles et ceux qui
construisent et qui rendent possible le
Paris des Jeux Olympiques 2000 2024 pour
pour l'été prochain donc je crois très
sincèrement que ça ne fera pas un appel
d'air cela permettra justement d'
appliquer la loi et je ne doute pas mes
chers collègues comme vous l'avez dit
que vous aurez cette même vigilance pour
sanctionner ces employeurs qui
consciemment emploi aujourd'hui de
manière irrégulière des sans papiers
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
Gontard merci Madame la madame la
Présidente moi je voudrais effectivement
qu'on se repose peut-être la question de
de ce qu'est un une travailleuse ou un
travailleur sans papier parce que j'ai
l'impression que voilà
on parle comme ça c'est quoi une
travailleuse ou un travailleur sans
papier ce sont des travailleurs des
travailleuses tout simplement ce sont
des gens qui font un travail qui
exercent une activité qui permettent à
notre pays de fonctionner qui ont permis
à notre pays de fonctionner notamment
pendant le covid qui permettent que
notre pays puisse fonctionner
encore c'est quand vous allez dans un
hôtel des femmes des hommes qui vont
faire le nettoyage ce sont des gens qui
vont faire toutes les activités dont
nous avons besoin alors oui elles n'ont
pas de papier elles n'ont pas de papier
elles n'ont pas de papier mais par
contre elles ont la possibilité de
travailler c'est peut-être cette
question là qu'il faudrait se poser
pourquoi
-on cette possibilité de travailler
qu'est-ce que nous demandons tout
simplement cette possibilité ce droit au
travail et oui nous nous demandons un
droit au travail
inconditionnel pourquoi parce que le
travail c'est un c'est effectivement
l'émancipation c'est un lieu
d'intégration et donc nous demandons ce
droit au travail inconditionnel qui
permettrait d'éviter d'ailleurs qu'on
discute de tout ce qu'on a dû discuter
de ce travail illégal de comment on
empêche ce travail illégal on a besoin
que ces salariés ils soient encadrés et
moi je me demande quand même une chose
quand j'écoute les débats depuis 2 jours
qu'est-ce qui arrive à la droite
qu'est-ce qui vous arrive hier ça a été
une descente en règle de la valeur
famille
alors la famille ça ne serait plus le
lieu de l'émancipation ça serait plus le
lieu de l'intégration il faudrait tout
faire tout mettre en œuvre pour éviter
la famille et puis là aujourd'hui ce
soir c'est la valeur travail celle dont
vous nous avez parlé cette valeur
travail que vous ne souhaitez pas qui ne
serait plus justement la valeur voilà on
le voit ce débat qui se tend de minutes
en minutes et on peut le dire on a
attaqué vraiment ce qui touche au cœur
du projet de loi immigration car les
sénateurs ont entamé depuis 18h45 depuis
18h45 l'examen de l'article 3 celui sur
les titres de séjour dans les métiers en
tension le débat qui va s'amplifier dans
les prochaines minutes toujours dans le
contexte de cet accord entre la droite
et le centre au Sénat qui sont tombé
d'accord pour supprimer cet article 3
selon ces sénateurs le fait de créer une
régularisation de droit pour les
travailleurs étrangers pour créer un
appel d'air selon ces sénateurs retour
de ce grand direct de Public Sénat à 22h
on retrouve AA également avec nous un
Mathias Aris qui suit tous les
événements depuis la tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle n'hésitez pas aussi à
lire les analyses de